je vais vous parler ce soir
blême qui va mal
vous accompagner tout au long de votre
vie
tout au long de votre vie qui concerne à
la fois le sujet climatique et le sujet
énergétique c'est un couple que l'on
peut aborder en parlant d'abord à
monsieur ou d'abord madame comme on veut
parce qu'en fait vous allez voir que les
deux se répondent beaucoup l'un à
l'autre et alors ce soir j'ai décidé de
commencer par le climat mais j'aurais
aussi bien pu décider de commencer par
de l'énergie
nous sommes depuis maintenant deux
siècles rentrer dans ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler l'anthropocène pour ceux
d'entre vous qui de vieux souvenirs de
géologie ont peut-être fait mal à la
tête vous savez qu'il ya des ères
géologiques la planète a connu des
heures géologie qui ont souvent un nom
qui se termine par scène le pliocène
l'éocène je sais pas quoi scène etc
et alors maintenant nous sommes depuis
on va dire un petit siècle rentrer dans
une ère qui s'appelle l'anthropocène
alors pourquoi anthropocène parce que
l'homme est devenu un agent géologique
alors il est pas tout seul pour ça il
faut qu'il soit monté à 8 milliards
depuis qu on était quelques milliards en
fait c'est déjà le cas c'est à dire que
nous avons acquis à cause de notre
nombre et de notre pression militaire
sur l'environnement une capacité à
modifier la terre à l'égal des grands
phénomènes géologiques qu'ils ont
modifié de par le passé
l'un de ces phénomènes il y en a
plusieurs mais l'un de ces phénomènes
concerne l'impact de l'homme sur le
climat
et ce phénomène il commence avec la
courbe que je vous montre là qui est un
une courbe qui vous donne les émissions
de ce qu'on appelle des gaz à effet de
serre que nous mettons dans l'atmosphère
alors les gaz à effet de serre c'est
quelque chose qui porte en physique une
définition assez précise c'est des gaz
qui ont la capacité d'intercepter les
infrarouges de grandes longueurs d'onde
émis par la planète tu l'infrarouge ça
vous dit quelque chose
oui non oui oui voilà donc vous savez ce
que c'est donc c'est du rayonnement
électromagnétique de plus grandes
longueurs d'onde que la lumière qui est
émis par la surface de la planète
or la surface de la planète rayonne de
l'infrarouge tout simplement parce que
la surface de la planète reçoit
elle-même de l'énergie du soleil et elle
restitue cette énergie notamment
rayonnement infrarouge
il se trouve que un certain nombre de
gaz présents dans l'atmosphère alors pas
les deux principaux c'est à dire ni la
zone d'oxygène
mais un certain nombre d'autres espèces
chimiques présentes dans l'atmosphère
sont opaques au rayonnement infrarouge
or je veux dire autrement est longue et
d'absorption dans les infrarouges de
grandes longueurs d'onde émises par la
planète
ces gaz
l'homme va enfin à plus exactement
depuis maintenant quasiment deux siècles
contribué à augmenter la quantité qu'il
y en a dans l'atmosphère et on a fait ça
parce que nous avons augmenté les
émissions de ces gaz à effet de serre
que nous mettons dans l'atmosphère le
premier gaz à effet de serre par ordre
d'importance dans l'atmosphère c'est la
vapeur d'eau mais l'homme n'a pas d'
influence directe sur la concentration
atmosphérique en vapeur d'eau
tout simplement parce que la terre est
couverte aux deux tiers d'océan alors
oublie de temps en temps parce qu'on
n'habite pas vraiment dessus mais
l'essentiel de la surface planétaire est
couverte d'eau donc la terre est une
énorme machine à évaporer et ceux qui
déterminent la concentration
atmosphérique en vapeur d'eau c'est la
température de l'atmosphère pas les
émissions humaines donc les aéro fait
gérant qui crache un peu de vapeur d'eau
ça n'a strictement aucune espèce
d'importance dans la teneur
atmosphérique en vapeur d'eau
le deuxième gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère pendant d'importance et
dioxyde de carbone ou co2 et alors là
l'homme va modifier la concentration
atmosphérique on valoir dans pas
longtemps puis après il ya d'autres gaz
notamment le méthane protoxyde d'azoté
et c'est ici ce que vous voyez c'est
donc les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de notre espèce depuis un siècle
et demi alors oui depuis un siècle et
demi ça ne fait que croître et embellir
donc si vous cherchez une croissance
structurelle de long terme cher à bercy
voilà vous en avez au moins une
c'est les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre dont vous voyez que depuis le
début de cette série
ça n'a jamais cessé d'augmenter alors ça
n'a jamais cessé d'augmenter même et y
compris quand on s'est mis à faire de la
tertiarisation de l'économie ou quand on
s'est mis à faire du digital ou quand on
s'est mis à faire des nouvelles énergies
renouvelables
quand vous voyez que aujourd'hui ça
augmente ça augmente sans cesse et là
dedans vous ne voyez rien de
discriminant pas plus les conventions
climat le fait qu'on en parle dans les
journaux etc
tout ça est parfaitement indifférent au
fait que pour le moment ça continue à
croître et embellir et en particulier la
digitalisation l'économie et sa
tertiarisation sur le fait qu'ils aient
plus d'emplois de services n'ont
absolument pas fait baisser cette courbe
pas plus que le fait qu'on ait mis des
gens dans les villes ce qui est de temps
en temps porté au crédit d'une plus
grande efficacité énergétique
les déplacements et dans l'habitat alors
c'est vrai mais vous allez voir dans pas
longtemps qu'en fait si on peut mettre
beaucoup de monde en ville c'est qu'on
est dans une société sous perfusion
énergétique dans une société qui est
sobre en énergie on peut pas mettre
beaucoup de gens dans les villes pour
des raisons alimentaires on y reviendra
plus tard l'essentiel par dont le
principal gaz à effet de serre que nous
émettons c'est à dire le co2 est en
occident les co2 c'est dioxyde de
carbone c'est donc un oxyde et là si
vous avez des vieux souvenirs de chimie
vous savez probablement que les oxydes
sont des formes et moléculaire stable
dit autrement pour qu un oxyde 16 des
trân oxydes il faut lui amener de
l'énergie ce qu'on appelle le réduire
pour enlever l'oxygène qui est cramponné
à son carbone là et qui a aucune envie
de lâcher
donc le dioxyde de carbone étant une
molécule chimiquement stable une fois
qu'il est dans l'atmosphère il est
éternel
il n'y a aucun processus spontanée
d'épuration du dioxyde de carbone tant
qu'il est dans l'atmosphère
cet avis est éternelle pour que le
dioxyde de carbone c pure de
l'atmosphère
il faut qu'ils viennent au contact du
sol et là vous allez avoir deux
processus qui vont l'épuré le premier
c'est la photosynthèse la croissance des
plantes
encore faut-il que les plantes soit dans
des conditions environnementales où
elles peuvent croître
donc s'il se met à faire trop chaud trop
froid trop secs etc
il ya plus de photosynthèse puisque les
plantes meurent et si vous avez les
conditions que nous avons récemment en
australie en sibérie ou en californie ou
au brésil ou en afrique et que ça crame
il ya pas non plus de photosynthèse
c'est l'exact inverse qui se passe le
deuxième processus d'épuration du co2 de
l'atmosphère c'est la dissolution du co2
dans l'océan
c'est donc un processus de contact avec
la surface océanique et c'est un
équilibrage de pression partielle que
vous avez peut-être vu les gens en
thermodynamique
c'est à dire que s'il ya
proportionnellement plus de co2 dans
l'air que dans l'eau et bien alors au
contact de ces deux compartiments fluide
vous avez du co2 qui passe de l'air dans
l'eau mais c'est un processus
réversibles
c'est à dire que si un jour on se met à
retirer le co2 de l'atmosphère ou s'il
se retire tout seul pour dieu sait
quelle raison
à ce moment une partie du co2 qui s'est
mis dans l'océan ressortira pour se
recoller dans l'atmosphère il ya un
processus
c'est une réaction qui est tamponné à
cause de du fait que le co2 temps qu'il
est dans l'air est éternel
et que les deux processus d'épuration
sont des processus de contact avec des
limites pour que les plans de pouce faut
pas que l'océan sature etc je vais
maintenant vous montrer une courbe qui
explique pourquoi la question du
changement climatique va vous
accompagner toutes les années qui vous
reste à vivre vous et vos descendants
comme moi et mes descendants
vous avez ici le surplus de co2 qui
reste dans l'atmosphère après arrêt des
émissions dit autrement demain matin on
se dit oh et tout ça c'est quand même
trop grave donc craque on arrête
totalement les émissions
c'est totalement fictive vous allez voir
c'est pas grave on arrête les émissions
et bien ce que vous dites ce graphique
c'est que au bout d'un siècle
une petite moitié du surplus de co2 que
notre espèce a créé dans l'air sera
toujours la queue au bout d'un millier
d'années 20% de ce surplus sera toujours
là et que au bout de dix mille ans 10%
au moins de ce surplus sera toujours là
et en fait quasiment là pour l'éternité
ce que je suis en train de vous montrer
c'est la raison qui explique pourquoi le
changement climatique est un processus
avec une inertie absolument considérable
et pourquoi à partir de maintenant la
notion de stabilité climatique est une
notion du passé c'est à dire pour toutes
les années qu'il me et qu'il vous reste
à vivre
le climat sera instable le climat s'est
mis à dériver et il va continuer à
dériver et il a cessé d'être stable et
il cessera à partir de maintenant d'être
stable ce qui est encore en notre
possession être pouvoir c'est pas
d'arrêter le réchauffement climatique
c'est limiter la dérive
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont fait du
bateau vous ne pouvez plus supprimer le
courant traversier voit juste empêché
d'être un peu trop fort c'est juste ça
vous pouvez faire
ce problème va donc s'échelonner sur des
échelles de temps pardon pour la
répétition qui sont celles d'une ou
plusieurs vies humaines alors que nous
avons pris l'habitude dans la société
dans laquelle nous vivons de gérer les
problèmes sur des pattes tant qu'ils
sont extrêmement courts
oui avec ses déclarations récentes je
pense qu'il a fait ce qu'il fallait
pouvoir là c'est bon
sur des patent qu'ils sont extrêmement
courts par rapport à l'échelle du
problème aujourd'hui n'est pas de temps
dans lesquelles nous vivons c'est
quelques années quand il s'agit d'un
mandat électif
c'est quelques années quand il s'agit de
la stratégie de long terme d'une
entreprise et donc pour les ingénieurs
qui sortiront de cette école que vous
alliez travaillé chez les fournisseurs
de services pour les municipalités ou au
sein des municipalités votre orientant
ce sera trois ans les bonnes années
l approche des élections ce sera plutôt
six mois et quand ça commence à aller
mal dans une société cotée c'est aussi
plus tôt six mois donc on est sur des
pattes temps qu'ils n'ont aucune espèce
de pertinence vis-à-vis du problème à
traiter qui demandent des directions qui
vont être soutenus pendant des décennies
ou des siècles pour que nous soyons
capables de limiter la casse et de nous
adapter à la dérive que nous avons mise
en route
on est là il ya un problème d'asymétrie
des échelles de temps entre le problème
est aujourd'hui ce que nous faisons dans
nos actions qui est absolument sais pas
si je dois dire matic
mais en tout cas qui est un des noeuds
du un déni de la sphère alors à cause du
fait que nos émissions croise et que le
co2 à une inertie considérable une fois
mis dans l'atmosphère vous avez ici la
traduction physique de ce que je viens
de vous dire sur la quantité de co2
présente dans l'air alors ce graphique
il est gradué en millilitres par mètre
cube ce qu'on appelle des parties par
million en volume ppmv dans le jargon
des physiciens
donc c'est emilie particules et si vous
mettiez d'emilie de votre carte dans un
véhicule de cocktails ça fait pas
beaucoup de votre carte donc avec ces
petites concentrations
est ce que vous voyez sur ce graphique
c'est que ça augmente doucement depuis
le début de cette série est non
seulement ça augmente mais ça augmente
de plus en plus vite puisque vous voyez
que cette courbe elle est légèrement
convexe n est pas tout à fait droite
elle est légèrement complexe alors vous
pouvez à nouveau sur cette courbure
recherché où est le début de la
tertiarisation de l'économie qui est
censée la dématérialisée
où est le début du digital et du
numérique qui est censée la
dématérialiser ses travaux loyer nulle
part et vous pourriez également vous
demander où est le résultat des
négociations climat on peut aussi se
demander
voyez ici vous avez la première année où
les pays qui ont signé la convention
climat se réunissent pour commencer à
discuter de la manière dont on va la
mettre en application
1995 95 chez les belges cette coop 1
s'est tenue pour la petite histoire dans
un pays qui s'appelle l'allemagne avec
un ministre de l'environnement à
l'époque qui se prénommait ang et là
c'est la même main merkel 1997 ont signé
le protocole de kyoto qui dit que les
pays dits riches c'est à dire en gros
les plus avancés dans
l'industrialisation acceptent de réduire
en valeur absolue les émissions qui ont
lieu chez eux voyaient l'effet que ça
donne
2009il ya eu là la réunion de copenhague
qui a été qualifié d' échec par les ong
etc en fait ce n'était ni plus ni moins
un échec que les précédentes étaient un
succès ou que paris a été un succès ce
que vous voyez pour le moment c'est que
l'évolution de la quantité de co2 dans
l'air est totalement indifférente à ce
qui peut se raconter dans les kops
alors en fait le résultat d'une coop
d'une conférence des parties là d'une
réunion annuelle
c'est très exactement ce que le
journaliste a envie d'en dire rien
d'autre c'est juste que journaliste a
envie d'en lire si on vous demande d'en
sur une paillasse de faire une
expérience et que vous voyez que le
résultat de l'expérience est totalement
indifférents à la valeur d'un paramètre
c'est que vraisemblablement ce paramètre
n'a aucun rôle dans l'expérience que
vous êtes en train de faire
eh bien là c'est exactement ce que vous
voyez
l'évolution de la quantité de co2 dans
l'air est totalement indifférente à ces
clips à ce qui peut se raconter dans les
négociations annuelles sur le climat est
en fait il ya une très bonne raison à ça
c'est que ces négociations annuelles
prennent place dans un cadre qui est un
cadre onusien et les cadres onusiens
sont des cadres unanime
dit autrement il faut que la totalité
des pays soient d'accord
consigne l'accord qui prend place à la
fin des négociations
alors si à certains d'entre vous vous
êtes un peu jeune pour ça enfin non pas
son copropriétaire mais ont des parents
qui sont copropriétaires
ça revient à ce que vous mettiez 204
prier terre dans une salle et que vous
leur disiez on va discuter d'un montant
de travaux
vous avez un pot propriétaire une voix
quelle que soit la superficie de votre
appartement
par contre vous paierez au prorata de la
superficie et vous devez vous mettre
d'accord à l'unanimité sur un programme
de travaux équipe a décidé à l'avance en
sachant très exactement ce que vous
allez faire et qui paye quoi
voilà pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
déjà fréquenté des assemblées de
copropriété la preuve il ya pas de
syndic
il ya personne pour vous proposer des
résolutions rien d'accord on la
probabilité qu'on arrive à un résultat
rigoureusement nul dit autrement dans ce
genre d'endroit vous ne fait
qu'entériner ce que les gens sont déjà
prêts à faire rien de plus et c'est très
exactement ce qui se passe dans ce cadre
du bien c'est pas de la gare à la
solution comme le co2 à une grande
inertie dans l'air vous avez ici un
ensemble de courbes qui en sont la
traduction sur ce qu'on appelle le
réchauffement climatique alors je dis
tout à l'heure les gaz à effet de serre
sont des gaz qui ont la particularité
d'absorber les infrarouges terrestre ça
veut dire que quand vous augmenter leur
concentration dans l'atmosphère
vous avez une plus grande proportion des
infrarouges terrestres qui sont absorbés
près de la surface sans pouvoir
s'échapper vers l'espace
donc vous allez réchauffé par effet
d'absorption de l'énergie près de la
surface
la température de surface
corrélativement vous allez aussi
refroidir la stratosphère parce que si
vous avez plus de rayonnement capter
près de la surface il en reste moins
pour réchauffer les hautes couches de
l'atmosphère
donc l'un des marqueurs de l'élévation
de température au sol par supplément
d'effet de serre c'est que la
stratosphère se refroidit ce qui ne
serait pas le cas si c'était l'intensité
solaire qui augmentait parce qu'à ce
moment là on recevrait plus de
rayonnement en eau de l'atmosphère et en
particulier plus de rayonnement
ultraviolet absorbé par l'ozone qui se
trouve dans la stratosphère et donc à ce
moment
stratosphère se réchauffera le fait que
la stratosphère se refroidissent depuis
les 40 sur les 40 dernières années ce
qu'on voit très bien avec des ballons
sont qui vont mesurer la température
c'est le marqueur indiscutable du fait
que le réchauffement qu'on est en train
de vivre en ce moment il est bien due à
un supplément d effet de serre et pas
induire un supplément d'activité solaire
d'accord c'en est une preuve irréfutable
il y en a d'autres enfin celle de la
marche très bien on rajoute donc du co2
dans l'atmosphère et d'autres gaz à
effet de serre donc la température près
du sol s'élève alors ici vous avez une
courbe qui par deux il ya un peu plus
d'un siècle et qui va jusqu'à un peu
moins l'assiette dans un peu moins d'un
siècle et qui vous donne la manière dont
se comporte la température moyenne de la
surface ans je rappelle que la
température moyenne de la surface est
une construction intellectuelle
personne d'entre vous ne mesurent la
température moyenne de la surface
vous vous savez avec votre peau mesurer
ou apprécier plus exactement la
température qui fait tout de suite dans
cette salle et en allant vous balader
dans la rue
vous savez apprécier la température qui
fait aujourd'hui à paris vous ne savez
pas avec vos sens apprécié la
température qui fait aujourd'hui à
melbourne où au milieu du pacifique
donc rien que la température moyenne de
la planète
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas capable moi
non plus de l'apprécier avec vos sens et
encore moins la moyenne sur une année où
la moyenne sur un siècle
donc je vous rappelle que la moyenne est
une construction intellectuelle c'est
quelque chose qui ne s'apprécient pas
avec ses sens ce que vous alors ici
c'est une évolution relative évidemment
un ce que vous dit ce graphique c'est
que la température de la planète elle a
déjà commencé à s'élever elle s'est
élevée d'à peu près 1 degrés aujourd'hui
un peu plus d'un degré c'est déjà
suffisant pour que on est des grands
pontes forêt qui s'assèchent et qui
brûle un peu partout c'est déjà
suffisant pour qu'on ait un certain
nombre d'autres perturbations notamment
des perturbations du cycle de l'eau avec
des moussons qui deviennent plus
intenses tombant sur des sols plus secs
etc
enfin on a déjà un certain nombre de
phénomènes qui sont devenus plus
désagréable juste un degré et les
courbes de couleurs que vous avez pour
l'avenir vous donne l'élévation de
température qu'on pourrait avoir d'ici à
la fin du siècle en fonction du scénario
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
consultants on crache plus ou moins de
gaz à effet de serre ce que vous voyez
de particulièrement marquant sur ce
graphique c'est que pour
et vingt prochaines années toutes les
courbes de couleurs se superposent ce
qui est une façon de dire que
l'évolution climatique des 20 prochaines
années est déjà totalement embarqué dans
nos émissions passées et elle ne elle
sera la même quoi que nous fassions sur
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans les 20 prochaines années
dit autrement à partir du moment où on
commence a décidé d'agir sur les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
commence à différencier l'avenir
vingt ans plus tard alors je vais
prendre un parallèle pour ceux d'entre
vous qui ont le permis de conduire ça
revient à dire qu'une voiture qui est en
train d'accélérer et de se rapprocher
dangereusement bas mur au moment où vous
appuyer sur la [ __ ] de frein tout ce
qu'elle fait c'est qu'elle sait qu'elle
accélère encore plus fort pendant les
vingt ans qui suivent d'accord donc vous
comprenez que si on commence à s'occuper
de nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
au moment où on approche où on a franchi
un certain nombre de seuil de danger
malheureusement ça ne permettra pas de
réparer la situation que nous
souhaiterions éviter ou d'éviter la
situation que nous souhaiterions éviter
d'accord ça ne permettra pas de le faire
à cause de la grande durée de résidence
du co2 dans l'air et de l' inertie
considérable du système climatique dont
je le répète le système climatique sa
dérive des 20 prochaines années
elle est totalement écrite avec ce qui
s'est passé en terme d'émissions
totalement peut plus rien y faire et
donc ça va augmenter va continuer de
demandes envoyées que si on se place à
l'échelle du siècle entre j'arrête à peu
près dé m demain matin et je crache le
plus en plus tant que ça passe
eh bien vous avez une dispersion assez
large des élévations de température avec
quelque chose qui pourrait se limiter à
2° transitoirement avant de redescendre
un peu plus dans le meilleur des cas
rassurant rouge arrête demain matin
enfin je diminue très très très
rapidement les émissions
on verra après de combien est ici c'est
tant qu'il ya du charbon je tape dedans
mais voit en gros c'est ça le talent
inné pour savoir combien quelques degré
d'élévation de la température c'est
enquiquinant encore une fois comme la
moyenne c'est une construction
intellectuelle
eh bien il faut essayer de voir si un
d'autres moments il serait pas passé
quelque chose d'un peu significatif qui
nous permet de prendre nos repères
vous avez ici une carte des écosystèmes
qui sont installés en europe si on ne
les supprime pas alors c'est quand je
dis actuelle c'est plutôt début du 21e
ou fin du xxème siècle si on ne supprime
pas les écosystèmes existants pour faire
des trucs essentiels comme les villes et
des trucks utiles comme des chants des
routes
et autres pistes de ski donc si on
supprime pas les écosystèmes en place
pour y mettre autre chose qu on a plus
envie de voir
non on a essentiellement des forêts en
europe en france on a essentiellement
des forêts dites tempéré avec des arbres
à feuillage caduc dans le nord
essentiellement des conifères tout au
nord ici il fait trop froid et trop sec
pour que vous ayez des forêts et de la
toundra est ici fait trop sec pour que
vous ayez de la forêt dont vous avez de
la steppe
mais enfin l'essentiel de l'europe est
couverte de forêts si on l'enlève pas
pour faire autre chose voilà l'europe il
y a vingt mille ans alors il ya vingt
mille ans dans le cadre des variations
naturelles du système climatique parce
que le système climatique a
naturellement varié au cours des ères
géologiques c'est bien pour ça dure est
que les ères géologiques portent des
noms différents
ça se rapporte généralement à des
configurations différentes du système
climatique 1 par exemple ya une grande
transition au moment de l'extinction des
dinosaures
c'est une grande transition climatique
et un refroidissement brutal causé par
la chute d'un astéroïde puis des
éruptions volcaniques massive
donc en général ccdr géologiques sont
marquées par des climats qui changent
enfin exactement les limites des ères
géologiques sont marqués par lé climat
qui change donc il ya vingt mille ans
dans le cadre des grandes variations
climatiques de l'ère quaternaire on est
au milieu d'une ère glaciaire envoyé que
le climat est un peu différent de ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui et le la
géographie est un peu différente aussi
la première différence d'importance et
que vous oubliez erasmus en suède il ya
plus de suède vous l'oubliez tout autant
au danemark et vous l'oubliez dans le
nord de l'allemagne
mais ça excite peut-être moins de monde
vous voyez également que
les écossais et les irlandais ont cessé
d'être les enquiquineurs pour le tournoi
des six nations sont également sous la
glace et enfin les lyonnais peuvent
aller faire du ski ski aux pieds en
descendant de leur immeuble
puisque les glaciers des alpes comme
vous le voyez ont considérablement
grossi donc vous avez énormément de
glace qui s'est créé sur l'europe
vous avez également une énorme calotte
glaciaire posé sur le canada donc ya pas
plus d'erasmus au canada pour ceux qui
auraient été tentés d'aller y voir et le
groenland et l'antarctique ont également
un peu grossi pour faire toute cette
glace il faut prendre l'eau quelque part
l'eau a été prise dans l'océan et comme
le fond de l'océan est toujours au même
endroit et bien le niveau de l'océan a
baissé de 120 m c'est la raison pour
laquelle pour ceux d'entre vous qui
connaît cette anecdote on rentre à pied
dans une grotte qui s'appelle la grotte
cosquer qui aujourd'hui à une entrée
sous marine qui est située à 30 mètres
sous l'eau en méditerranée alors la
grotte elle même est hors d'eau mais
l'entrée est sous l'eau à l'époque
évidemment il y avait pas scaphandre
autonome puisque les hommes
préhistoriques sont pas prêts antérieurs
à cousteau et donc ils rentrer dans la
grotte cosquer à pied maintenant le fait
que ce soit sous l'eau c'est parce que
l'eau a monté depuis donc le niveau de
l'eau était 120 mètres plus bas et donc
ya pas de club voilà le iv p en tout cas
pas pour les faire des regards dans la
manche et plus de manches
le climat étant beaucoup plus froid il
est beaucoup plus sec beaucoup moins de
précipitations et du coup les
écosystèmes installés en europe de
l'ouest
à cette époque là c'est de la steppe et
de la toundra donc ça ressemble en gros
au nord de la sibérie actuelle et dans
cet écosystème désolé et bien la
population française est celle d'un
petit arrondissement parisien
or donc c'est ce que la totalité du
système france est capable de fournir
comme nourriture à un animal en bout de
chaîne alimentaire qui est manifestement
quand on est passé de l'état de gauche à
l'état de droite ça s'est situé dans le
cadre d'un réchauffement planétaire
il ya quand même assez peu de gens qui
arrivent à faire fondre les glaces ont
adhéré en le refroidissant donc ce
réchauffement planétaire qui a permis à
la géographie de changer totalement pour
passer de cette géographie là à cette
géographie là à l'échelle de la planète
c'est uniquement 4 à 5 degrés en cinq à
dix mille ans voilà la transition
voilà le réchauffement climatique
qui a donné lieu à la transition
environnementale qui a permis ou qui a
occasionné plus exactement le passage du
paysage de gauche au paysage de droite
alors maintenant avant de rentrer dans
les détails
quand vous voyez ça vous comprenez
facilement que si c'est ça le résultat
d'une expérience grandeur nature qui a
consisté à élever le thermomètre
planétaire de 4 ou 5 degrés en 5 ou 10
bilan vous comprenez bien que
l'expérience qui consiste à les lever de
la même amplitude thermique en un siècle
se terminera par un choc extrêmement
brutal ou occasionnera plus exactement
d'échangés extrêmement brutaux qui
dynamitent rond partout les sociétés
stables et prospères
dit autrement ça sera partout la guerre
et la dictature parce que les sociétés
humaines n'y résisteront pas c'est ça
que ça veut dire et ça met en cause
à l'évidence aussi la taille et
l'espérance de vie de la population
mondiale
moi je ne sais pas dire 602 juin dans ce
genre de transition il reste 7 8 6 5 4 3
2 ou 1 milliard d'individus j'en ai fait
autrement aucune idée en tout cas je
pense en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que la question se pose la question se
pose en ces termes alors voilà quelques
quelques réjouissances qui sont au menu
dans cette histoire donc là vous avez eu
le paysage général du restaurant à tapas
et maintenant je vais vous donner
quelques tapas pris un parent qui
correspondent à mon propos ici je vous
montre une première carte qui vous donne
le nombre de jours où les conditions
extérieures sont létale dont un mortel
on ne peut pas se tenir en conditions
extérieures dont deux jours dans l'année
dans un monde qui s'est réchauffée de 4
degrés par rapport à aujourd'hui
alors dans un monde comme ça alors
pourquoi est-ce que ces concentrés aux
tropiques pour une raison en fer
l'équateur plus exactement pour une
raison assez simple à l'équateur comme
vous le savez l'air et facilement saturé
d'humidité
quand vous êtes dans un air saturé
d'humidité tant que la température
extérieure est inférieure à celle de
votre peau qui est de l'ordre de 35
degrés parce que votre peau n'est pas à
37 elle est un peu en dessous et entre
35 et 36 donc temps que l'air extérieur
est inférieure à 35 degrés vous pouvez
avoir de la déperdition thermique par
rayonnement pouvait pas en avoir par
évaporation puisque l'air est saturé
d'humidité et à partir du moment où la
température extérieure passe au-dessus
de 35
et d'ailleurs la température de votre
peau vous ne pouvez plus perdre de
chaleur ni par rayonnement ni par
évaporation et vous mourrez
d'hyperthermie même si vous êtes en
bonne santé
si je vous place dans une étuve
c'est à dire dans une température
extérieure de 40 degrés avec un air
saturé à 100 % d'humidité bourré dans un
air sec non mais dans un 1er set toutes
natures et à sang vous transpirez mais
dans un air saturé à 100 % d'humidité ou
clem c'est donc le là ça vous donne le
nombre de jours par an où ça sera pas
possible de se tenir à l'extérieur
envoyé il ya quelques régions qui sont
gentiment peuplé aujourd'hui il ya
l'inde l'indonésie de 150 millions
d'habitants une partie de la chine une
partie de l'asie du sud est aurait
endroits qui sont quand même gentiment
peuple et il est absolument évident que
ce genre de mode de deux camps dire
d'obstacles dans ce genre de pays ça
causera bien avant qu'on en arrive là
des migrations tard que les gens
resteront pas les bras croisés à mourir
ni partiront avant et quand vous fait
migrer et quelques centaines de millions
quelques milliards d'individus
même s'ils vont pas très loin
généralement ça remue un peu dans le
coin quoi donc là vous avez par exemple
un déterminant qui vous explique
pourquoi ces régions là vont
nécessairement devenir instable dans le
cadre d'un climat qui se réchauffe un
peu trop deuxième élément qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est que le réchauffement
climatique occasionnera globalement plus
d'évaporation donc plus de
précipitations je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure quand on le canton réchauffe
l'atmosphère
en fait ça augmente sa capacité d'emport
en vapeur d'eau
globalement mais manque de chance pour
nous ce surplus de précipitations ne
sera pas répartis de manière homogène ni
dans le temps ni dans l'espace alors les
épisodes cévenols qu'on vient de vivre
c'est ce que c'est un épisode cévenol
sait quand il pleut des trombes d'eau
sur gare et alès là ce qui vient de se
passer il ya deux jours alors en fait un
épisode cévenol c'est une masse d'air
chaud qui remonte de la méditerranée en
chargeant d'humidité et à ce moment
quand elle rencontre les cévennes elle
monte en altitude se refroidit et
occasionne des précipitations très
intenses
c'est ça un épisode cévenol et plus vous
avez une différence de température
marquée entre la terre et la mer
plus il a fait chaud et que vous pouvez
avoir de l'air saturé d'humidité et plus
ça vous fait des phénomènes intense donc
là il ya des endroits où il est tombé un
demi mètre d'eau en l'espace de 24
heures
ça fait quand même beaucoup puisque un
demi mètre d'eau c'est un peu en dessous
de ce qui tombe à paris en une année
donc paris hilton 700 millimètres d'eau
dans l'année donc c'est donc donc c'est
il suffit enfin comment dire vous pouvez
avoir une augmentation des
précipitations avec deux épisodes de
cette nature dans l'année et 0 puis le
reste du temps pas terrible pour faire
pousser les plantes beaucoup mieux du
gond crachin breton qui tombent tous les
jours donc si vous voulez avoir un
commentaire des conditions favorables à
la végétation
l'intensification des précipitations
ramener sur des courtes périodes de
temps ça fait pas du tout votre affaire
1 or malheureusement il va y avoir cette
évolution dans le cadre du réchauffement
climatique ce que vous voyez également
c'est que ya un certain nombre de
régions qui vont globalement s'assécher
dans le cadre de ce réchauffement
climatique c'est à dire que c'est des
endroits où va globalement moins
pleuvoir et vous envoyer en particulier
une
il se trouve que c'est chez nous j'ai
envie de dire entre guillemets c'est le
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen et ce
graphique un peu compliqué à comprendre
vous dit c'est juste être courbé là qui
est intéressante vous donne la baisse
des précipitations sur le pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen pardon en fonction
de l'élévation de température d'envoyer
à 2° c 20% à 4 degrés c'est 40% ça va
évidemment baissé l'humidité des sols la
vouvoyer les endroits où l'humidité des
sols va baisser donc le pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen encore une partie
des états unis l'afrique du sud qui
commence déjà à avoir des problèmes et
une partie de l'australie sur des et
vous voyez également un endroit qui est
un peu inquiétant c'est la forêt
amazonienne
donc ça va contribuer à un stress
supplémentaire en plus de celui qu'elle
suivit à cause de la pression agricole
et dans ces endroits là évidemment ça va
gêner à la fois les écosystèmes naturels
et les cultures
donc ça ça veut dire qu'une partie des
écosystèmes naturels vont mourir une
partie des arbres en france par exemple
vont sont en train de mourir parce
qu'ils ne sont pas adaptés aux
conditions qui sont en train de
s'installer trop chaud trop sec
du coup ils n'arrivent pas à s'hydrater
où il rentre il s'appelle
ici rentrer en compétition avec des
ravageurs qui finissent de les tuer par
exemple les scolytes en ce qui concerne
les épicéas donc ça ça a déjà commencé
1° et c'est évident qu'à 3 degrés une
très large partie des forêts françaises
actuelles aura disparu entre ça et les
incendies vous allez également avoir une
baisse des rendements agricoles toujours
pour les mêmes raisons parce que les
plantes vont être stressé sur une
planète où les démographes goodies il va
y avoir de plus en plus de monde alors
est-ce qu'il va y avoir de plus en plus
de monde il ya de moins en moins à
manger
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas complètement
suivant à un moment la régulation de la
population s'effectuera je ne sais pas
si ça sera juste le fruit de notre
volonté aussi ce sera des choses plus
désagréable qui s'en chargeront voici un
graphique qui vient du dernier rapport
de ce qu'on appelle le giec
alors le giec c'est le groupe
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat
en anglais ça s'appelle eyed peas ici
pour internacional panel on climate
change et c'est une instance onusienne
également qui fait toutes les 5 à 6 ans
une évaluation de ce que la science et
je dis bien la science pas le café du
commerce ni paris match ni le monde
mais la science dit sur l'impact de
l'espèce humaine sur le climat
donc c'est une compilation d'articles
scientifiques qui résumée en quelques
centaines de pages c'est un peu lourd et
dans un rapport récent qui portait sur
qui s'appelait changement climatique et
r on trouve en particulier sur graphique
et alors je vous invite à regarder la
barre de droite la barre de droite elle
vous dit alors le code couleur c'est que
quand on est dans le violet on est dans
quelque chose d'irréversible et de
généraliser elle vous dit qu'à partir de
2 degrés et demi 3 degrés vous aurez de
l'insécurité alimentaire généralisée sur
terre dit autrement il y aura des
problèmes d'accès à la nourriture un peu
partout l'accès à la nourriture
problématique
ça a toujours miné la stabilité des
sociétés humaines quand tu ce cas
commence à être un problème de pouvoir
se nourrir
en général la population est instable
population est stable ça vous fait des
révoltes des guerres du terrorisme c'est
[Musique]
des migrations qui elle même fondée
révolte des guerres du terrorisme bref
ici vous avez une carte qui vous donne
la propension à
à s'enflammer des forêts françaises à la
fin du xxème siècle est ici vous avez la
même chose en 2040 alors il est probable
au vu de ce qui s'est passé cet été
qu'on est en train de prendre un peu
d'avancé donc ce que vous voyez c'est
qu'en 2040 la forêt landaise sera aussi
inflammable que la forêt méditerranéenne
aujourd'hui est que la forêt de
fontainebleau par exemple sera aussi
inflammable que la forêt landaise du
début du xxème siècle à la fin du 21e
siècle
la quasi totalité de la france
enfin la totalité de la france sera
aussi inflammable que l'arrière-pays
méditerranéen aujourd'hui la totalité de
la france je voulais dit tout à l'heure
le réchauffement climatique est un
réchauffement pas de la surface et
corrélativement un refroidissement de la
stratosphère ce qui veut dire que le
gradient de température entre la surface
et la stratosphère augmente alors la
différence de température entre les deux
a tendance à augmenter
du coup ça veut dire que la puissance de
la pompe convective l'aspiration qui met
en route tous les phénomènes un peu
violent qu'on a dans l'atmosphère des
tornades
les orages et les ouragans va avoir
tendance à s'intensifier les modèles qui
sont des outils numériques qui sont
capables de dire quelque chose sur les
ouragans mais pas sur les tornades et
sur les orages parce que les maïs sans
trop large vous disent que on s'attend à
ce que les ouragans deviennent plus
intenses et on sait à peu près ce qu'on
constate actuellement les ouragans sont
en moyenne en train de devenir plus
intense il ya toujours un sujet de débat
sur le nombre mais par contre sur
l'intensité la tendance avait déjà
caractérisée et ça va s'amplifier sur
les tornades et les orages les modèles
ne disent rien parce que c'est des
phénomènes qui sont trop petits pour
être évalués par des modèles numériques
qui ont des mailles qui font leurs 200
km de côté mais la logique voudrait
qu'il leur arrive quelque chose aussi
encore une fois puisque à partir du
moment où on augmente le gradient de
température entre la surface et la haute
atmosphère qui devrait se passer quelque
chose
et la logique voudrait que ça il
notamment dans le sens aussi d'une
intensité augmenter le groenland a
commencé à fondre
alors le groenland a commencé à fondre
tout simplement parce qu'il fait trop
chaud et une des raisons pour lesquelles
il fait trop chaud autour du groenland
c'est que la banquise a commencé à
fondre à l'entente la banquise fond
savoure en place une surface
particulièrement réfléchissantes qui est
de la glace par une surface
particulièrement absorbante qui est
l'eau océanique et à ce moment là
température environnante augmentent
encore plus vite puisqu'il ya plus de
rayonnement solaire qui reste absorbé
avec la glace il était réfléchi avec
l'eau il est absorbé d'accord donc ça
chauffe plus vite et comme la
température ambiante augmente avec ce
phénomène d'amplification ça réchauffe
suffisamment l'air pour que le groenland
et commencer à fondre une fois que le
groenland a commencé à fondre il
s'arrête plus il s'arrête plus parce que
c'est un processus de fonte et non pas
de désintégration de la calotte quand ça
fond le haut de la calotte baisse
d'altitude plus le haut de la calotte
baisse d'altitude
plus la température ambiante augmente un
pour ceux d'entre vous qui font de la
montagne vous savez que quand vous
montez en altitude la température baisse
et que quand vous redescendez dans la
vallée la température remonte donc quand
vous perdez de l'altitude la température
monte donc si le haut de la calotte perd
de l'altitude et bien la température
environnante dans le haut de la calotte
baisse augmente pardon et du coup la
fonte s'accélère
le deuxième processus qui prend place
c'est que à la surface de la calotte
vous avez des poussières qui sont amenés
par le vent à partir du moment où tu vas
t'en vous n'avez pas de fonte
les poussières sont recouvertes par des
couches de neige successives et
disparaissent si la neige en surface
font les poussières réapparaissent se
concentre et ça rend la surface de plus
en plus grise et noire est donc ça
absorbe le rayonnement solaire encore
plus vite et ça augmente encore plus
fort la température tous ces processus
sont des processus qui d'auto
amplification il ya aucun processus
d'amortissement là dedans
donc à partir de maintenant quoi qu'on
fasse allez on va dire la moitié au
moins de la calotte groenlandaise va
disparaître en quelques siècles ça va
mettre un peu de temps et ça ça nous
garantit trois mètres d'eau en plus dans
l'océan mondial
en plus de la dilatation thermique de
l'eau qui fait aussi monter le niveau de
l'océan
du côté de l'antarctique de l'ouest le
phénomène est un peu différent là c'est
la déstabilisation des langues terminal
des glaciers qui flotte sur l'eau qui
est le problème parce que cette calotte
repose pour l'essentiel sur un socle qui
est sous marin le socle rocheux de
l'antarctique de l'ouest est pour
l'essentiel posée sous l'eau ce qui veut
dire que quand les langues terminal des
glaciers commence à être rongés par de
l'eau de plus en plus chaude après l'eau
peut s'infiltrer entre le fond rocheux
qui est sous la mer et la langue de
glace ça accélère la descente du glacier
qui vient du haut de la montagne vers la
mer et ses l'antarctique de l'ouest est
une espèce de châteaux de cartes
c'est à dire que c'est un ensemble de
glaciers arc bouté les uns sur les
autres et si vous commencez à chasser
les cartes qui sont près du niveau de la
mer vous avez le risque que tout le
reste brada baoum alors ça se fait pas
en une semaine non plus ça va aussi
prendre un petit moment mais pour le
groenland
comme pour l'antarctique de l'ouest vous
avez le risque que tout ça se
déstabilise en quelques siècles
alors en ce qui concerne l'antarctique
de l'ouest le potentiel d'élévation du
niveau de la mer va c'est plutôt de s'y
mettre
donc si je rajoute l'antarctique de
l'ouest et le groenland
d'ici quelques siècles le trait de côte
de l'europe du nord pourrait ressembler
à ça voilà donc ça veut dire que ceux
d'entre vous qui iront se préoccuper du
destin de ville côtière dans le cadre de
ce que je disais tout à l'heure
eh bien on peut pas envisager le destin
d'une ville côtière dans le cadre d'un
contexte stable il y aura plus jamais de
contexte stable pour les villes côtières
pour les milliers d'années à partir de
maintenant plus jamais la meilleure va
continuer à monter pendant des milliers
d'années
quoi qu'on fasse le co2 qui est repris
par l'océan conduit ce dernier à être
moins alcalin on appelle ça la
signification alors c'est pas vraiment
une acidification puisque vous voyez ici
le ph éboué qui descend pas en dessous
de cette donc l'océan ne va jamais
devenir acide par contre il devient
moins basique il est actuellement
légèrement basique et c'est une très
bonne chose qui soit légèrement basique
parce que c'est nécessaire pour que
plein de micro-organismes de maquereaux
organise puis synthétiser du calcaire
alors il n'y a pas que les huîtres
délicieux
ce qui synthétise du calcaire il ya
aussi tout un tas de bestioles qui
vivent dans l'eau et notamment une
partie du phytoplancton et du
zooplancton en particulier du
zooplancton synthétise du calcaire salle
une soeur de squelettes ou ça lui sert
de coquilles le calcaire qui se trouve
aujourd'hui dans les couches géologiques
de la terre ça n'est que des coquilles
de petits animaux marins qui ont vécu
dans les temps anciens et c'était des
toutes petites coquilles sauf quand vous
trouvez un fossile de n'importe quoi
d'ammonites ou de quelque chose
trilobites mais sinon c'est que des tout
petits animaux
donc il en fallait vraiment beaucoup
pour faire les couches géologiques de
calcaire que nous avons aujourd'hui donc
il ya du phyto et du zooplancton dans
l'océan il y en a beaucoup qui dépend de
la synthèse du calcaire si l'eau
commence à devenir trop proche d'un ph 7
cette synthèse devient impossible et
donc ce plancton mais enfin moeurs
disparaît et donc une partie du début de
la chaîne alimentaire marine est un
risque
dans le cadre du climat qui se réchauffe
et de l'océan qui s'assied d'ici il ya
plus d'un siècle
un chimiste suédois qui s'appelait are
in us avaient déjà compris que dans le
cadre d'un supplément d'effet de serre
on allait avoir une température qui
augmenterait plus vite au pôle cottereau
pic
c'est à cause de sigma t4 pour ceux qui
s'en rappellent donc arrhenius avait
compris ça et à partir du moment où vous
avez un climat qui se réchauffe plus
vite au pôle contre aupic ça veut dire
que la différence de température entre
le pôle et les tropiques s'affaiblit et
l'affaiblissement de cette différence de
température a deux conséquences
la première c'est que elle va ralentir
ce qu'on appelle là ce qu'on appelle lui
à tort le gulf stream mais qui en fait
s'appelle la dérive nord atlantique qui
vient des tropiques et qui va s'enfoncer
au sud du groenland un courant océanique
qui fait sens et le deuxième effet que
ça va avoir c'est que ça affaiblit ce
qu'on appelle le vortex polaire c'est à
dire la limite séparative entre la
navigation circulaire de l'air autour du
pôle et le climat tempéré des moyennes
latitudes il ya une limite séparative de
ses deux clients qui est assez marquée
quand le pôle est beaucoup plus froid
que
les moyennes latitudes quand le pôle
devient moins froid toutes proportions
gardées
et bien cette limite séparative
s'affaiblit et c'est ce qui explique
pourquoi on peut avoir comme c'est
arrivé l'hiver dernier je crois
successivement des records de shows et
des records de froid parce que vous avez
à ce moment plus facilement des
incursions d'air polaire aux moyennes
latitudes et plus facilement alors là ce
moment vous avez un record de froid et
plus facilement des incursions d'air des
moyennes latitudes aux pôles et à ce
moment vous avez des records de choses
au mieux l'hiver le 1er janvier 2018 je
crois que c'est 2018 vous aviez 1er
janvier un haut lieu de la nuit polaire
vous aviez une température positive au
pôle nord il a fait + 4 je crois ce jour
le 1er janvier en pleine nuit polaire
donc ça c'est une conséquence de
l'affaiblissement de la différence de
température entre les pôles et les
tropiques
le réchauffement climatique va
globalement augmenter la température du
gros bouillons de culture que constitue
la planète terre et ça les petites bêtes
mon bien-aimé
alors je suis pas en train de vous dire
que le ou la copine je sais jamais moi
j'aime bien dire le coc vide parce que
pour moi c'est le virus par la maladie
mais enfin pourquoi un peu importe donc
le des petites bêtes
il y en a un certain nombre qui vont
bien aimé qu'il fasse un peu plus chaud
et donc on devrait avoir une
modification des agressions sanitaire
que bien évidemment très peu de gens
sont capables d'anticiper de façon fine
le climat était globalement moins
variable qu'il ne l'ait qu'il est en
train de le devenir
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya un certain
nombre de stocks de carbone qui s'était
immobilisée sur terre soit dans le sol
gelé en permanence qui s'appelle le
permafrost soit dans les couches
inférieures des sols là où il ya des
arbres par exemple et racines etc et une
partie de ce stock de carbone va être
remis en circulation dans un climat qui
se réchauffe rapidement alors tout ça va
produire des atteintes directes ou
indirectes c'est bien évidemment les
indirects qui sont les plus difficiles à
modéliser la teinte indirectes c'est
vous commencez à avoir une baisse de
rendement des céréales aux états unis du
coup le prix des céréales augmente aux
états unis du coup les états unis sont
pas contents parce qu'ils se retrouvent
en compétition avec la chine pour en
trouver chez paou et du coup ils se
tapent dessus
bon ben là vous aurez une un risque
sanitaire indirects due au changement
climatique
c'est le fait que les deux pays se
tapent dessus qui va causer quelques
morts et quelques quelques problèmes
avec une cause initiale qui elle-même en
temps en temps que tel nom n'aurait pas
causé autant c'est évidemment très très
difficile de faire un inventaire précis
de ce qui va arriver aux sociétés
humaines
tout ce que vous pouvez dire c'est que
si vous secouez de plus en plus fort un
édifice qui n'en avaient pas l'habitude
il va y avoir des craquements de manière
croissante dans le système mais savoir
très exactement où quand comment
personne ne peut vous le dire donc ce
que on peut vous dire ce que la science
peut vous dire c'est vous préciser un
peu ce que je vous ai raconté ce soir
c'est à dire vous préciser un peu les
endroits où on imagine que les cultures
vont souffrir un peu plus vite que
d'autres en fonction de la nature de la
culture de ceci de cela ça sera pas
considérablement plus détaillée que ce
que je vous ai raconté ce soir par
contre une chose qui est absolument
certaine c'est que quand on est comme on
est en train de faire pour la première
fois une expérience totalement inédite
qui est d'appliquer une transition qui
va là qui va sans fois plus vite qu'une
des glaciations 100 fois plus vite
qu'une des glaciations à une humanité
sédentaires de 8 milliards d'individus
on n'a jamais fait ça est bien la seule
certitude c'est qu'on aura des surprises
et comme le dictionnaire est bien fait
ça veut dire que ça sera des processus
pour lesquels on n'aura pas prévu le
coup et donc on sera démunis en termes
de réponse est de ce point de vue le coc
vide et est un cas de figure intéressant
d'accord c'est un truc pas anticipé qui
nous arrive sur la figure personne n'a
rien demandé
et au moment où il faut aussi où il faut
s'y mettre et bien les mesures de
réponse sont pas très sympathique et
c'est encore pas très grave
le coc vide je veux dire malheureusement
le changement climatique va nous
réserver bien pire alors une fois qu'on
en est arrivé là
peut-être qu'on peut se dire bon tout ça
ça n'a pas l'air drôle a donc même si on
a bien compris qu'il ya des claques
qu'on n'allait pas éviter on va quand
même essayer d'éviter le plus gros alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait que fait la police
agissons bande d'incapables ces
politiques etc alors pour ça je vais
vous donner maintenant un ordre de
grandeur qui est important sur ça veut
dire quoi d'agir vous avez ici à un
graphique qui vous donne un ensemble de
courts superposés qui vous donne la
réponse en température du système terre
en fonction des émissions cumulées et si
vous aller jusqu'au bout de la courbe en
fait c'est les émissions cumulées
jusqu'en 2100 alors ses émissions jeu
cumulé jusqu'en 2100 peuvent être
d'ampleur variable peuvent aller jusque
là et donc si vous résumer l'ensemble de
ses courbes à une seule en gros elle
vous dis une chose cette courbe elle
vous dit voilà de combien le système
terre va se réchauffer entre 1850 et
2100 fin à l'ère préindustrielle et 2100
en fonction de la quantité totale de co2
que je mets entre 250 et 2100 alors ses
10 ans 50 et 70 sur les deux axes mais
en fait entre 50 et 70 s'est rien passé
donc c'est pas très grave on peut mettre
250 dans les deux cas de figure donc en
gros en fonction de la quantité totale
de co2 que je crache dans l'atmosphère
entre le début de l'ère industrielle et
2100 voilà quelle est la réponse en
température du système et ça vous voyez
que ça fait une droite alors
applications pratiques afin de ville 18
l'espèce humaine avait rajouté deux
mille deux cent cinquante milliards de
tonnes de co2 dans l'atmosphère et donc
nous avons déjà signé pour 1 25 degrés
de réchauffement
dit autrement si j'arrête les émissions
demain matin de toute façon la planète
se réchauffera de 1,5 degré
donc quand ou madame hidalgo ou
n'importe laquelle ou lequel de ses
collègues dit on va réussir à limiter le
réchauffement climatique à 1,5 degré
c'est pas possible
pour ça il faut tuer tout le monde et ne
plus rien et m à partir de la semaine
prochaine
alors donc les 1,5 degré parfois avancé
dans des discours politiques
physiquement ils sont morts c'est
terminé d'accord ils sont morts philippe
les 1,5 degré on va se les prendre de
toute façon dans les 20 ans qui viennent
quoi qu'on fasse
même si on arrêtait des maîtres demain
matin si on veut se limiter à 2 degrés
ce qui se trouve aussi dans les discours
de madame hidalgo et bien à ce moment il
faut que l'espèce humaine donc pas juste
les parisiens se limite à trois mille
milliards de tonnes de co2 dont 2250 ont
déjà été émises
accor dont vous êtes allés au casino aux
alliés 3000 euros vous en avais déjà
paumé de 1250 d'accord avec moi que il
vous en reste plus que 750 a paumé
si je suis cette trajectoire
ça veut dire en particulier si j'ai une
évolution continue sur les émissions que
les émissions planétaires doivent être
divisée par 3 je dis bien par trois
d'ici à ce que les gens dans cette salle
n'est même pas mon âge dans les 30 ans
qui viennent
d'accord d'ici à ce que vous n'ayez même
pas mon âge il faut que les émissions
planétaires soit divisée par 3 je vais
vous le dire maintenant autrement pour
ceux d'entre vous qui sont les rois
d'excel si vous demandez à excellent de
vous faire la racine 30e d'une division
par trois vous prenez excellent vous lui
demandez un tiers ça fait combien la
racine 30e et bien excellent va vous
dire que ça fait de l'ordre de 0 96 de
mémoire ou 0,95 mettons 0,95 ce qui veut
dire que le fait de tenir les deux
degrés suppose que à partir de la
semaine prochaine les émissions
planétaires baisse de 5% par an donc
tous les ans les émissions doivent être
inférieurs de 5% à celles de l'année
précédente
or il se trouve qu'une baisse de 5% des
émissions planétaires
c'est ce qu'on aura en 2020 à cause du
coc vide donc il faut un covit
supplémentaires tous les ans
supplémentaires tous les ans pour que on
tienne la limite des 2 degrés voilà
c'est ça la promesse politique quand on
vous dit on va tenir les deux degrés
alors vous comprenez bien que ça va être
un peu compliqué à faire avec le
consommateur qui reste assis dans son
fauteuil et les politiques qui se
contente de faire de grandes
déclarations puis derrière de faire
l'exact inverse de ce qu'ils ont dit
qu'ils feraient s'est pas vraiment avec
des chèques à air france et aero donc on
va y arriver même si j'ai rien contre
eux air france airaudo alors ses
émissions qu'il faudrait diviser par
trois d'ici à trente ans doit ce qu'elle
sorte
vous avez ici un petit panorama alors
c'est une seule cuisine maison moins que
j'ai fait
par exemple dans le panorama que je vais
vous montrer les émissions de ce qu'on
appelle les industries de l'énergie donc
par exemple les pétroliers et les
charbonniers n'existe pas en tant que
tel je les aient réintégré dans les gens
qui utilisent le charbon et les gens qui
utilisent le pétrole
j'ai enfin voila j'ai fait une ma petite
cuisine donc s'est décomposé par
activités aval
alors à laquelle on se parle
20% des émissions planétaires sont dues
aux centrales à charbon donc les
centrales à charbon qu'est ce qu'on y
fait et on brûle du charbon qui est un
composé carbonées résidus de vie
ancienne pour faire de la chaleur et
ensuite cette chaleur on s'en sert pour
actionner une machine de carnot donc
cette machine de carnot à partir de la
différence de température on va vous
actionnez un alternateur et 7
alternateur va vous produire de
l'électricité 20% donc des émissions
planétaires tout gaz à effet de serre
confondues viennent des seules centrales
à charbon la moitié du parc de centrales
à charbon actuellement en fonctionnement
dans le monde se trouvent en chine
l'autre moitié un peu partout après vous
en avez un gros paquet aux états unis en
inde au japon et en australie
après c'est encore 7% des émissions
planétaires viennent des centrales à gaz
et à fuel alors même motif même punition
on brûle du gaz au rôle du fioul ont
fait une machine de carnot ont fait
d'électricité donc en gros pas loin de
28 % des émissions 27 28 % des émissions
viennent de la production électrique à
base de combustible fossile
ça ne vient évidemment pas de la
production électrique à base de barrage
de centrales nucléaires d'éoliennes et
de panneaux solaires ça vient des
centrales à charbon à pétrole et à gaz
l'électricité au charbon c'est 40 %
d'électricité dans le monde et
l'électricité au gaz c'est à peu près 25
d'électricité au pétrole c'est à peu
près cinq jeux sur un peu moins à chaque
fois mais peu importe 6 à 7% des
émissions dans le monde viennent des
cimenteries donc les cimenteries c'est
autant que les centrales à gaz dans le
monde
ça fait quand même un gros paquet de co2
le ciment qui est évidemment cher à la
ville de paris puisque sans ça en fait
pas de logements sociaux autrement qu'en
bois mais on va voir qu'on a un petit
problème pour faire des logements en
bois pour tout le monde et bien le
ciment se fait en cassant deux des
molécules de carbonate de calcium
c'était le cadre de calcaire le
carbonate de calcium caco3 et dans des
fours à ciment qui sont des ans des
tubes dans lesquels vous portez la
température à plus de 1000
gray et bien la molécule de carbonate de
calcium se casse en deux et vous avez de
la chaux vive d'un côté c'est à eau et
co2 de l'autre co2 par dans l'atmosphère
donc en fait la production de ciment
conduit à l'émission de co2 de deux
manières différentes
à cause de la réaction chimique que vous
avez dans le four et à cause par
ailleurs du fait que vous avez besoin
d'un combustible pour créer les plus de
1000 degrés dans le four est que ce
combustible va vous occasionner des
émissions de co2 quand vous faites
brûler n'importe quoi du gaz du charbon
ou même des vieux pneus un gros 10 %
vient des émissions directes du reste de
l'industrie relatant vous avez appris 4%
pour les hauts fourneaux enfin pour
l'aciérie où on réduit du minerai de fer
avec du coq et à ce moment ça vous fait
du co2 puis après vous avez la
production de plastiques et la chimie de
base qui sont également des gros postes
d'émission
retenez que dans l'industrie ce qui
aimait énormément c'est de fabriquer les
matériaux de base donc métaux plastiques
chimie de base ciment le fait derrière
de transformer l'acier ambulant de 12
c'est beaucoup moins émetteur ce qui
veut dire que en matière de choses que
nous allons jeter un jour ce qui coûte
le plus en termes d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre c'est pas de les jeter cd
avoir fabriqué donc il vaut beaucoup
mieux ne pas acheter que acheté pour
bien jeter ce qui est important c'est de
ne pas acheter parce que c'est à ce
moment là que les émissions de
fabrication ont eu lieu par exemple pour
les bouteilles en plastique vaut mieux
ne pas et ne pas les acheter que bien
les jeter un exemple 5% ou 6% des
émissions planétaires ces chaudières de
bâtiments par exemple ce bâtiment est
probalement chauffer l'hiver pour le
moment le climat n'est pas encore assez
réchauffer pour que l'on soit dans
climat californien et il ya pour le
moins une chaudière dans ce bâtiment
si cette chaudière fonctionne au gaz ou
au fioul elle rentre dans ce
compartiment
et même si elle est au chauffage urbain
ils rentrent aussi parce que le
chauffage urbain fait du co2 si vous
avez des transports pardon c'est 14% des
émissions dans lesquelles en ordre de
grandeur
je vous aime il aux chiffres le premier
chiffre significatif les voitures c'est
à peu près 6 les camions à peu près 4 la
marine marchande à peu près 2 et le
transport aérien à peu près 2 avant que
vides en fait c'était deux et demi avant
que vider ses problèmes en plus tôt un à
un et demi aujourd'hui ce que vous voyez
sur à ce moment là c'est que les
cimenteries c'est un aussi gros
problèmes dans le monde que les voitures
en termes de climat c'est que les
chaudières de bâtiments et les voitures
c'est à peu près pareil
mais les centrales électriques c'est
plus gros que la totalité des terres les
centrales électriques au charbon c'est
plus gros que la totalité des moyens de
transport en termes d'émissions de co2
l'agriculture c'est 20% des émissions
alors dans l'agriculture vous allez
trouver essentiellement des gaz qui ne
sont pas du co2 mais qui sont aussi des
gaz à effet de serre 20 des gaz qui
absorbe les infrarouges terrestre vous
allez en trouver deux importants
le méthane alors le méthane c'est le gaz
de la putréfaction vous savez c'est le
gaz qui se forme naturellement dans les
marécages et qui donne les feux follets
quand il rencontre du phosphore qui
s'enflamment spontanément ya du méthane
il s'en forme dans les estomacs des
vaches et je dis bien les parce qu'il ya
un 4 et dans les estomacs des autres
ruminants et moutons les chèvres les
mouflons maison nombreux puissants sympa
donc les estomacs des vaches les vaches
il y en a à peu près un milliard et demi
sur terre donc le poids des vaches c'est
à peu près équivalent au poids des
hommes est la deuxième source de méthane
dans l'agriculture c'est les rizières
parce que les rizières c'est des
marécages artificielle donc c'est des
endroits dans lesquels il ya des débris
organiques qui se décompose à l'abri de
l'oxygène de l'air et ça vous fait aussi
du méthane le deuxième gaz importants
vous allez trouver dans l'agriculture
c'est le protoxyde d azote qui est un
gaz qui est émis par les engrais azotés
qui soient naturelles ou de synthèse
quand vous les épandez dans les champs
donc que vous mettiez du des déjections
de vaches de cochon ou des engrais
venant de chez le fabricant d'engrais du
coin de la grande paroisse et bien vous
allez avoir des émanations de n2o quand
vous mettez les engrais par terre donc
ça c'est essentiellement des gaz or co2
le diesel détracteurs là dedans c'est
extrêmement minoritaire 10% des
émissions c'est la déforestation la
déforestation c'est quoi ces jeux coupe
je roule la déforestation est le
corollaire inévitable de la croissance
démographique
ça fait des siècles que ça existe
l'europe a massivement déforester entre
l'an 1000 et l'an 1800 parce qu'elle
était en pleine croissance démographique
couvert forestier européen était de
l'ordre de 80% en l'an 1000 il est passé
par un minimum à 15% en 1850 avant que
les forêts soient sauvés du soit sauvé
delà de la boulimie des forges puisque
c'est les forges qui bouffaient
énormément de bois par le charbon
donc en fait c'est le charbon qui est
sauver les forêts parce qu'on a changé
de combustible pour la fabrication de
l'acier
donc ça c'est essentiellement pour
obtenir de nouvelles surfaces
alimentaires dont vous voyez que
l'alimentation au sens large
si j'inclus la déforestation les
émissions directes de l'agriculture
c'est un tiers du problème et là vous
avez deux déterminants qui joue à plein
le nombre de bons hommes sur terre et la
fraction de viande dans la ration
alimentaire parce que plus on mange de
viande en particulier de gros animaux et
plus il faut cultiver de végétaux pour
nourrir les animaux
donc si on n'aime pas la déforestation
il ya essentiellement deux trucs à faire
c'est s'occuper de la population la
taille de la population mondiale est par
ailleurs s'occuper de la part carnet
dans l'alimentation est enfin là il y
envoie risque quelques poudre de
perlimpinpin le traitement des déchets
les fuites de fluides frigorigènes etc
mais quelque 90 ans grille alors voilà
vous avez ici le panorama de ce qu'il
faut diviser par trois choisis ton camp
camarade
on commence par quoi et nous allons 30
ans n'a pas de 150 on a 30 ans donc
c'est comme ça que se pose le problème
quand vous le regardez de façon très
macroscopique de fait là dedans une
partie mais une partie seulement des
émissions vient de l'énergie vous voyez
qu'il ya un gros paquet des missions qui
ne vient pas de l usage de l'énergie
donc assimilés
la lutte contre le changement climatique
avec la transition énergétique s'est
partiellement vrai il ya de grandes
zones de recouvrement entre les deux
mais c'est pas exactement la même chose
c'est pas exactement la même chose dans
la partie climat il ya un déterminant
agricole et forestier qui n'existe pas
dans la transition énergétique en face
au canton va retrouver le bois comme
combustible mais et si on se limite à la
transition énergétique on n'a pas
couvert toute cette partie là des
émissions par ailleurs on en reparlera
peut-être au moment des questions
la transition énergétique que nous avons
mise en route en france à un gros
morceau qui est hors climat puisque tout
le débat sur la part du nucléaire dans
le mix électrique qu'on remplacerait par
d'autres sources qui n'émettent pas de
co2 est un débat hors climat c'est pas
parce qu'on fait ça qu'on est plus
avancée ou moins avancés sur la partie
climatique c'est à côté
remplir remplacer du nucléaire par des
éoliennes ça fait rien gagné sur le plan
du climat
on va donc parler d'énergie l'énergie
quand on évoque ce mot il ya quelques
réflexes pavloviens qui viennent souvent
à l'esprit et qui aurait pu constituer
autant de réponses possibles pour ce jeu
que vous connaissez tous
et ce pré retraités que vous connaissez
tous aussi donc il aurait pu demander il
n'a jamais faire moi j'ai jamais vu une
session de questions pour un champion ou
qui veut gagner des millions pardon où
il demandait ce que c'était que ni l'un
ni l'autre du reste
oui demandé ce que c'était que l'énergie
alors là je vous mets pas les réponses à
l'avant sinon c'est pas drôle mais il ya
un certain nombre de réponses très
standard qui viennent à l'esprit des
gens et qu'on aurait pu mettre alors
bonne partie des gens quand on leur dit
énergie ils pensent facture c'est
particulièrement vrai quand vous au
travail
j'ai envie de dire quand dans une
entreprise vous dites énergie tout de
suite les gens pensent sa facture
d'électricité facture de gaz facture de
fuel facture de charbon à chaque camp et
ça coûte pognon c'est pas c'est pas
autre chose qui va leur revenir à
l'esprit quand vous êtes dans un endroit
où ce qui compte c'est de manipuler des
heureux toute la journée à leur manque
de chance quand on prend l'énergie par
cette entrée là on va tout de suite
allait mettre le problème dans un coin
parce qu'on va se rendre compte que
c'est une petite facture
si vous regardez ce que coûtent les
achats de pétrole de gaz et de charbon
dans le monde
rapporté à ce que les hommes gagnent
globalement ces quelques pour cent de
leurs revenus
même si vous prenez un français et que
vous regardez ce que lui coûte l'énergie
si vous empilez les carburants fortement
taxé le gaz l'électricité fortement
taxés etc
vous arrivez à 10 % de ce qu'il gagne
c'est 10 % du budget des ménages
mais donc ça se balade entre 5 et 10% et
donc à ce moment on va pas y passer la
nuit
comme disait l'autre on va s'occuper des
trucs qui coûte vraiment cher le loyer
pour les particuliers et les salaires et
les charges pour une entreprise encore
l'énergie on aura bien d'en voir plus
tard alors résonner de cette manière ça
vous masque quelque chose d'absolument
est crucial qui est que vous pouvez très
bien avoir quelque chose qui est très
faible en pourcentage avec l'unité que
vous avez regardé que vous avez prises
et qui pourtant est crucial pour votre
existence
si je prends votre cervelle par exemple
c'est toute petite partie de votre point
toute petite partie de votre point de
pourcent de votre poids mais enfin que
vous l'ayez ou que vous l'ayez pas ça
influe un tout petit peu sur le reste de
votre corps à corps
donc c'est pas parce que ça ne fait que
2 % de votre point que je peux vous
enlevez la moitié en dix ans beau ça
vous dit mme il y aura votre efficacité
de 1%
donc ça ne fait que 2 % de votre poids
et pourtant 100% de votre corps en
dépendent et j'aurais pu prendre
d'autres organes qui pèsent encore moins
lourds et dont votre corps dont dans
votre existence dépend de tout aussi
bien donc quand on raisonne en part de
camembert il ya un truc auquel il faut
faire extrêmement attention c'est que
les par toutes les parts du camembert
peuvent très bien dépendre d'une part
qui est tout petit avec la façon avec
l'unité que vous avez choisi donc oui
c'est une petite facture mais ce que
vous allez voir maintenant c'est que
100% du monde moderne en dépend deuxième
réflexe pavlovien qui vient souvent
qu'il faut l'économiser
car la meilleure énergie est celle qu'on
ne consomme pas vous avez tous entendu
ça du reste si vous tapez dans google la
meilleure énergie google vous complètera
votre votre quête avec c'est est celle
qu'on ne consomme pas alors mauvaise
réponse
on en a consommé de plus en plus alors
si on en a consommé plus en plus c'est
ou bien qu'on ait vraiment des crétins
puisque la meilleure c'est celle qu'on
consomme pas pour en être qu'on en
consomme est de plus en plus si la
meilleure ou bien c'est que cette maxime
et qu'on est en l'occurrence et cette
maxime qui est alors pas con mais qui
est fausse car vous allez voir là aussi
dans quelques minutes pourquoi est de
très loin la meilleure énergie c'est
celle qu'on consomme et pas du tout
celle qu'on ne consomme pas vous
retrouver sur cette évolution
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure sur
le fait qu' il n'y a jamais eu
dématérialisation de l'économie au sens
où on n'a jamais fait baisser cette
quantité de l'énergie qu'on n'utilise ni
avec la tertiarisation ni avec la
digitalisation ni avec machin etc
par contre ce que vous voyez également
sur cette courbe c'est que les nouvelles
énergies renouvelables que vous voyez
ici en rose donc c'est l'addition du
solaire de l'éolien pardon du solaire de
l'éolien de la géothermie du biogaz
des agrocarburants et de tous les
machins pouet pouet là qui font la une
des journaux et des discours de
politique ça vaut à peine l'encré du
journal pour en parler c'est tout petit
et non seulement c'est tout petit mais
depuis qu'on a commencé à en parler
c'est à dire par là ce qui a le plus
augmenté dans le monde et de très loin
ses des combustibles fossiles donc cédé
aux nerfs dont on parle le plus c'est
les combustibles fossiles qui augmentent
le plus
de là je vous livre une réflexion
personnelle qui est
ne décidez jamais rien de crucial dans
votre vie sur la seule base de la
lecture du journal fait jamais une
erreur pareille
jamais jamais jamais et quand vous serez
en fonction ce que je vous souhaite ne
fait jamais cette connerie encore quand
vous serez en fonction ne prenez jamais
une décision significative en fonction
d'une impression qui vous vient de la
lecture du journal
en fait jamais ça le journal est truffé
de conneries du début à la fin tous les
jours que dieu fait et tant vous
connaissez pas le secteur dans lequel
vous êtes sur le bout des doigts
vous ne savez pas faire la différence
entre un journal qui raconte des choses
justes ou un journaliste qui raconte des
choses justes et un journaliste qui
raconte des conneries
vous ne pouvez pas faire la différence
faut bien connaître le secteur de
l'intérieur pour finir par faire le
distinguo j'ai regardé il ya une dizaine
d'années maintenant quelle était la part
de chaque énergie dans ce qu'on appelle
le mx mondial c'est à dire la totalité
de l'énergie qu'on utilise dans le monde
est ce que vous voyez c'est que si je
regarde la part des combustibles
fossiles dans l'approvisionnement
mondial
et bien cette part est monté à à peu
près 80% au moment des premiers chocs
pétroliers et depuis elle est à 80%
un peu plus un peu moins un peu de
nucléaire un peu de gaz un peu de chez
pas quoi bref mais elle est aux
alentours de 80%
donc en fait la civilisation la
révolution industrielle a consisté à
faire monter cette part des combustibles
fossiles à 80% et à lille et c'est là
donc voilà deux mauvaises réponses
troisième réflexe pavlovien
quand on dit énergie maintenant c'est
100% weider tu sens que vous avez déjà
entendu ça y compris dans la bouche de
madame hidalgo
que on allait faire un monde 100 %
renouvelable d'accord du reste le
journal le 10 alouettes baril alors un
monde 100 % renouvelable
c'est très facile à faire ça ne pose
aucun problème
du reste on l'a fait très longtemps
voilà par exemple un monde 100 %
renouvelable
ça ne pose aucun problème de faire un
bond de 100% en double à bhl ici vous
avez un monde dans lequel vous avez des
transports qui sont 100 % renouvelable
que vous voyez là sur lola à terre une
énergie 100 % renouvelable on utilisait
le vend le bois etc du travail 100%
renouvelable tout cas renouvelables dans
ce monde là est en fait le monde des
hommes entre l'apparition de notre
espèce et il ya deux siècles a été 100 %
renouvelable en permanence donc ça ne
pose aucun problème de faire un monde
100 % renouvelable sujet juste le petit
sujet c est ce que ça va être possible
de faire 100 % renouvelable un monde qui
ne fait pas comme sur cette image 500
millions d'individus vivent 30 ans en
moyenne à la naissance et ayant le 100e
de votre pouvoir d'achat
c est ce qu'on va faire un monde 100 %
renouvelable
maintenant qu'on est 8 milliards sur
terre et 15 mille dollars de pib par
personne et par an et des gens qui
entendent trouver pour pêcheurs des
brosses allant des lunettes et le
dernier téléphone alors là j'ai une
réponse très simple à vous proposer non
pas une seconde
ça ne sera possible alors ce soir je
vais un peu manqué de temps pour faire
la démonstration
ça ne sera pas possible sauf dans la
bouche des politiques dont j'aimerais
bien que ils engagent leur main droite
de romain gauche et leur tête sur le
billot quand il promet de ce genre de
truc parce que ça n'arrivera jamais
alors nous avions une marine 100%
renouvelable et peut-être parce qu'on
était totalement stupide on est passé à
une marine 100% fossiles nous avions des
transports terrestres 100% renouvelable
et probablement parce que nous sommes
stupides nous sommes passés à des
transports terrestres 100% fossiles nous
avions une agriculture 100% renouvelable
et probablement parce que nous sommes
stupides nous sommes passés à une
agriculture 100% fossiles nous avions
une industrie 100% renouvelable est ici
une roue à aube en bois renouvelables
actionné par de l'eau renouvela d'une
rivière
nous v'la bhl est probablement qu'on
était idiot parce que on est passé à une
industrie 100% fossiles bref on avait
les renouvelables depuis très longtemps
sous la main et j'ai pas ou alors c'est
juste pour faire la série rivière et
voir dallas quoi mais on est passé à une
énergie fossile
alors je répète ou bien nos ancêtres
étaient des chrétiens comme des crétins
patentés ou bien il ya une vraie raison
physique à ce que nous ayons procéder de
la sorte est alors en fait
malheureusement il ya un peu de physique
derrière ça imaginons qu'on prenne le
volume d'air de 2 à 3 fois cette salle
et que on le fasse passer à 80 km heure
c'est à dire un bon mistral ou 45,2 pour
ceux d'entre vous qui font de la voile
dans une éolienne 45 général on est plus
on préfère aller se taper des coûts au
port plutôt que d'aller faire les ajouts
sur l'eau mais voilà donc 80 km/heure
fait passer ça dans une éolienne est
bien la quantité d'énergie que vous
allez récupérer en faisant passer cette
masse d'air dans une éolienne
c'est un demi de mp2 un poids de l'hers
et 1,2 kg par mètre cube vous pourrez
faire de calculs si ça vous amuse avec
un nez une éolienne qui en demandent à
peu près 40%
vous vous rendez compte que c'est la
même quantité d'énergie que celle que
vous avez dans la combustion de sap
pétrole alors question à votre avis pour
notre espèce
est-ce que c'est plus simple d'utiliser
un moulin à vent de faire passer mille
mètres cubes d'air dedans et d'avoir de
l'énergie
juste quand il ya du vent ou est-ce que
c'est plus simple d'aller faire un trou
trou dans la terre de ressortir quelque
chose qui tient dans ce volume dont vous
pouvez vous servir exactement quand vous
en avez envie
d'accord si c'est dans une lampe vous
éclairer quand il fait nuit et pas quand
et du vent et si vous mettez ça dans un
moteur vous avancez quand vous avez
décidé d'avancer est pas content et du
vent du reste la raison pour laquelle on
a mécanisé la marine à voile c'est
justement parce qu'avant les marins
mouret du scorbut quand t es pas devant
et que on s'est dit et que c'était un
peu difficile de respecter les horaires
et qu'on s'est dit que quand même
c'était plus simple avec un moteur qui
obéissait quand on appuyait sur le
bouton on a peut-être eu tort de faire
il y avait une raison physique mais ça
eh bien là c'est exactement la même
c'est physique et ça se retrouve dans
l'économie si vous utilisez une éolienne
aujourd'hui vous allez avoir votre
kilowattheure pour 3 400 enfin pour 4 à
8 centimes
mais quand il ya du vent et si vous
voulez avoir votre kilowattheure y
compris quand ya pas de vent et qu'il
faut le stocker et de restituer derrière
faut rajouter le coût du stockage donc
le vrai coût de l'électricité éolienne
rendu pilotable c'est à dire que vous
êtes capables de faire fonctionner le
vidéoprojecteur quand j'arrive est pas
juste quand il ya du vent
et bien c'est le prix du kilowattheure
multiplié par 3,6 par rapport à sa
sortie d'éoliennes de l'autre côté alors
qu'il ya déjà la fonction stop qui est
incluse
vous allez votre kilowattheure pour une
fraction de centimes donc en fait la
raison pour laquelle on est passé de là
à là c'est que ça a permis de diviser la
quantité de travail humain parce que
c'est ça le coup la quantité de travail
humain qui fallait pour extraire à
kilowattheure de l'environnement par
plusieurs dizaines et encore pour le
moment la vision n'est pas complète
parce que votre éolienne vous la
fabrique des combustibles fossiles vous
l'a fabriqué avec du charbon qui va
servir à faire le métal vous l'a
fabriqué avec du pétrole qui va servir à
transporter les constituants et vous l'a
fabriqué avec du gaz qui fait tourner la
cimenterie pour faire le plot en béton
le jour où vous n'avez plus de
combustibles fossiles parce qu'on est
passé à 100 % est d'ailleurs êtes
d'accord avec moi 100% ibère c'est qu'il
ya plus un gramme de combustible fossile
dans l'histoire à ce moment vous perdez
le charbon pour la métallurgie hamon
vous perdez le transport pour la
circulation des composants dont vous
revenez aux charrettes aux camions
fabriqués comme en cent pour cent au
vénère comment est-ce que vous fabriquez
d'acier des camions que avec du bois
mais le bois on veut aussi pour la
construction on lui aussi pour faire de
l'énergie eon veut enfin d'accord bon
donc si vous bouclez le système et que
vous regardez con mais ça vous coûte de
fabriquer votre kilowattheure éolien
dans un système boucler ça où il ya plus
un gramme de combustible fossile
il est évident que le coût de votre
kilowattheure éolien il va pas rester là
où il est aujourd'hui vous allez pouvoir
le x 20 fait très attention à un élément
que je vient d'illustrer tous les
raisonnements économiques sont linéaires
le monde et non linéaire vous êtes non
linéaire d'accord vous êtes totalement
non linéaire par exemple élévation de
température interne que vous supportez
c'est pas une fonction linéaire si je
vous montre de 1° votre température
interne vous serez un peu patraque
éventuellement où il viendrait pas ici
en plus voir une suspicion coville donc
ça sera vraiment mais c'est tout si je
vous montre votre température interne de
5 degrés vous vous ratez pas cinq
conférences et remorques or donc le
monde est totalement non linéaire fait
très attention l'économie est toujours
une approximation linéaire du monde
donc elle est valable dans le temps et
dans l'espace de façon instantanée mais
fait très très attention à travers quand
tous les économistes qui consiste à
passer du marginal aux moyens sans se
poser la question de savoir si c'est
légitime dit autrement ils prennent un
petit machin dans un coin et ils disent
on multiplie les volumes par cent mille
et les prix resteront les mêmes je vois
que oui bon pour moi ce n'est pas une
démonstration probante
donc voici trois mauvaises réponses
alors en fait la bonne vous allez le
voir c'est que l'énergie
j'ai coutume de résumer maintenant en
dix ans et ironman en pièces détachées t
sur l'énergie parce que l'énergie
en fait c'est des croquettes pour
machines c'est ce qui permet aux
machines de fonctionner et les machines
c'est iron man en pièces détachées
nous vivons aujourd'hui dans un monde de
machines toute personne dans cette pièce
qui aura touché aujourd'hui un objet en
acier aura bénéficié d'une machine qui
s'appelle à l'habit noir qui dispose de
la puissance de tous les bras de l'île
de france c'était un cas laminoir est
aussi puissant que 10 millions de paires
de bras toute personne dans cette salle
qui aura vous êtes laver les dents ce
matin parce que sinon on vous fait
gronder pas je crois qu'il y ait autre
conjoint vos parents un pur bref et bien
une glace ça sert d'un train devait
s'asseoir pardon d'un train de verre
float qui est une grosse grosse machine
qui est également puissantes comme des
millions de paires de bras vous portez
tous des vêtements qui ont été
acheminées jusqu'au magasin où vous les
avez achetés où il avait acheté à
distance par amazon ce qui est pas bien
parce que monsieur besoin c'est déjà si
riche comme ça mais à ce moment vous
avez eu besoin
deux camions pour l'acheminement c'est
des machines un camion ses puissants
comme quelques milliers de fois les
jambes du conducteur
vous avez bénéficié pour l'existence de
ces vêtements soient de grosses grosses
moissonneuses à cotton 6 et du coton
soit si vous portez des fibres
synthétiques
donc tout ce qui est poli machin
chouette et nylon à ce moment vous avez
bénéficié d'un bout de plate forme
pétrolière qui est aussi une très très
grosse machine puissante comme des
millions de paires de jambes ou deux
paires de bras etc etc
donc en fait nous vivons dans un monde
de machines vos vêtements ont été
fabriqués par des machines votre
nourriture et fabriqué par des machines
s'est transportée par des machines
vous êtes chauffé par des machines je
parle en ce moment dans une machine un
micro qui amplifie la voix etc
nous vivons dans un monde de machines
nous on joue plus rien on regarde les
machines travailler et comment font plus
rien a le temps de faire des études
entre autres choses il n'y avait pas
d'études longues dans un monde sans
machine il n'y avait pas de retraite
dans un monde sans machine il n'y avait
pas les 35 heures dans un monde sans
machine y avait pas de week-end et il
n'y avait pas de vacances d'accord tout
ça c'est du temps libre qui nous a été
dégagée parce que les machines possèdent
deux places et les machines bossa de
place parce que l'énergie leur permet de
travailler donc l'énergie c'est iron man
en pièces détachées
si quelqu'un dans cette salle a déjà
fait allez on va dire l'ascension du
mont blanc dans la journée est quelqu'un
qui a déjà fait l'ascension du mont
blanc dans la journée si en partant de
chamonix non personne
et bien si vous faites cet effort-là vos
jambes vont développer une puissance de
100 watts en moyenne dans la journée
beaucoup s'en wattin qui dans cette
salle a déjà utilisé un mixeur à souple
sa lettre qu'il fait là
est-ce que vous avez une idée donc une
paire de jambes en actions common
sportif 1 100 watts en moyenne sur 10
heures est ce que vous savez quelle est
la puissance de votre mixeur à souple
1200 watts payante la soupe déborda non
non ça fait 300 ou 400 watts un mixeur à
soupe mais quand même 300 ou 400 watts
ça veut dire qu'au moment où vous
appuyez sur le bouton pour faire dit
vous avez quatre cyclistes très bien
entraînés qui se mettent à pédaler pour
vous d'accord
ou vous avez le champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste qui se met à pédaler
pour vous paf on veut bien des gens vous
avez déjà passé un aspirateur
alors là pour le coup l'aspirateur est
dur et c'est pour ça que vous ne mettez
pas dans la soupe sinon le déborde lui
fait 1200 watts c'est à dire qu'au
moment où vous appuyez sur le bouton de
l'aspirateur vous avez douze cyclistes
qui se mettent à pédaler pour vous l'a
déjà monter dans un ascenseur à lhassa
moteur d'ascenseur ces quelques
kilowatts
donc au moment où vous appuyez sur le
bouton de laitages vous avez 50
cyclistes dans la cave qui se mettent à
pédaler pour vous au moment où le paysan
au monde sur son tracteur et ça c'est
pas un gros tracteur contraire autres
acteurs et bien à ce moment il ya des
centaines de cyclistes qui se mettent à
pédaler pour lui au moment où alors là
c'est plutôt des bras donc au moment où
l'ouvrier rentrer dans le tractopelle
parce que l'ingénieur de la ville de
paris lui a dit on va faire un trou à
cet endroit est bien à ce moment le
tractopelle se met à x plusieurs
milliers les bras de l'ouvrier en
question ça c'est iron man en pièces
détachées
je le redis c'est pareil rodman avec la
lumière au centre qui fait que la claque
mais c'est iron man quand même d'accord
ça démultiplie notre puissance par des
facteurs de milliers voire de millions
donc ici vous allez à la mémoire
industrielle un million de fois dont 10
millions de fois la puissance des bras
de l'ouvrier qu'il actionne et si je
prends un avion de ligne et bien un
avion de ligne développe la puissance de
1 million de fois celle des jambes du
pilote qui comme chacun sait est bronzée
jeunes bien entraînés et sportif
enfin pour ça c'est plutôt le jeune
copilote je pilote un peu moindre donc
aujourd'hui je le redis on vit dans un
monde de machines c'est les machines qui
bossent pour nous et c'est ce qui nous a
rendu la vie si douce alors ces machines
met en oeuvre une énergie qui est
absolument considérable aujourd'hui je
reprends mon ascensionnistes du mont
blanc alors là je vais être un peu sympa
avec lui je vais pas lui faire faire le
mont blanc en un jour mais en deux jours
mais peut-être des gens qu'on fait le
mont-blanc deux jours dans la salle
c'est déjà plus courant quand un jour
simon intentionnistes qui fait le
mont-blanc deux jours se paluche
alimente pas par le téléphérique de
l'aiguillé du midi
je précise il part à pied de chamonix
toutes les pieds se paluche 2000 mètres
de dénivelé dans la journée et bien à la
fin de la journée
cu et galen g h1 et bien il aura fourni
avec ses jambes
1/2 kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
corps donc quelqu'un qui lutte contre le
changement mutationnelles alors c'est si
vous n'allez pas mon achat maudit parce
que c'est un peu loin d'ici pour vous
amuser à monter 6,6 fois sur la tour
eiffel dans la journée à pied 1 précise
pas dans l'ascenseur avec les touristes
ça vous fera un effort identique si vous
faites ça un jour sur deux et bien à la
fin de l'année vous aurez développé 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique où
je vous le dit autrement vous fait 1000
mètres de dénivelé tous les jours du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre
à la fin de l'année vous avez restituer
100 kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique
si ces gros bras de vous fait travailler
retenez que l'ordre de grandeur est dix
fois plus faible donc c'est 10 kilowatts
heure d'énergie mécanique que vous allez
fournir sur une année si vous faites
fonctionner vos bras plutôt de la taille
de ce chat n est guère inquiété jeunes
pour pelleter de la terre 10 kilowatts
heure c'est ce que vous avez dans un
litre d'essence mais sous forme
thermique donc vous la fait passer dans
une machine de carnot un moteur et vous
retenez et vous récupérez pardon à
l'arrivée 2 à 4 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique ça veut dire comme
l'énergie est la marque de la
transformation parce que c'est ça en
fait sa définition en physique ça veut
dire que dans un seul litre d'essence
qui coûte le prix scandaleusement cher
de 1,042 qui se moque t'on vous avez la
même capacité à modifier l'environnement
que dans 10 à 100 jours de travail de
force d'un être humain
voilà d'où ça en votre pouvoir d'achat
voilà d'où sortent les études vous
là d'où sortent le temps libre voilà
d'où sort tout ce qu'on a vécu jusqu'à
maintenant et voilà d'où sortent les
villes je vais y venir après c'est à
cause de ça qu'on a eu les villes donc
les villes ce n'est pas une manière
d'économiser de l'énergie
c'est apparu parce qu'on avait plein
d'énergie julien je vais y revenir si on
parle argent ce qu on a bien compris
qu'en matière d'énergie il ya que ça qui
intéresse les gens
si je paye mon kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique avec un être humain au travail
ça va me coûter entre quelques centaines
et quelques milliers d'euros alors qu'en
face la machine me fournit le même
service le transforme environnement de
la même manière pour un coût marginal de
quelques dizaines de centimes
c'est à dire quelques centaines à
quelques milliers de fois moins que mon
être humain au travail voilà pourquoi on
a mécanisé absolument partout on a pu le
travail et où on a viré les gens pour
les remplacer par des machines
c'est beaucoup plus efficace pour
beaucoup moins cher
ça a même eu un impact sur
l'esclavagisme
vous savez qu'il ya quelques siècles il
y avait des esclaves c'était monnaie
courante
il ya eu des esclaves de tout temps il
avait du temps des romains il avait été
rappelé un esclave maintenant il va
encore mais quand même beaucoup moins
globalement alors est ce que c'est parce
que nous sommes devenus bons et qu'on
écoute amnesty international moi j'y
crois pas une seconde je crois que notre
code génétique est exactement le même
que celui de nos ancêtres dia de siècle
il n'y a pas la moindre différence
par contre il ya une petite différence
sur l'alternative à l'époque
l'alternative y en avait pas si vous
aviez envie d'avoir du travail vous
preniez des esclaves
maintenant il y en a une qui s'appelle
la machine alors regardons ce que coûte
un esclave esclaves en général c'est pas
une vocation de jeunesse vous l'avez vu
dans django là non il est pas content
donc si vous voulez avoir un esclave il
faut aller le chercher contre sa volonté
ce qui va vous coûter de l'argent
l'empêcher toujours comme dans django de
votes russie d ou de [ __ ] le camp
ce qui va aussi vous coûter de l'argent
le nourrir sinon il meurt ça vous coûte
de l'argent quand même ballot de perdre
quelque chose que vous avez acheté donc
si vous mettez tout ça boutabout vous
vous rendez compte que même le coût d'un
esclave va être de 10 à 100 fois
supérieur à celui de la machine qui elle
ne se met pas en grève n'a rien contre
sa condition de machines et aujourd'hui
sa détention n'est absolument pas
considéré comme quelque chose dit
ral alors que l'asservissement de nos
semblables oui donc la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes passés de
l'esclavagisme a pour l'essentiel
disparu c'est pas parce qu'on est devenu
intrinsèquement bon alors qu'avant on
était intrinsèquement des affreux c'est
tout simplement parce que ça n'a plus
aucune espèce d'intérêt de s'emmerder à
servir nos concitoyens alors que l'on a
une alternative qui est beaucoup moins
cher et beaucoup plus efficace
si je regarde bon ça je veux passer
rapidement à l'échelle d'un individu de
combien d'énergie en dispose je vais
convertir sa en croquettes pour machines
donc un individu aujourd'hui sur terre
utilisent de l'ordre de 20 mille
kilowattheures par an donc chaque
personne chaque terrien dispose d'un
approvisionnement énergétique de 20
mille kilowattheures par an donc il peut
distribuer des croquettes pour machines
à hauteur de 20 me kilowattheure et ça
ça permet de mettre en route un ironman
en pièces détachées qui a multiplié la
puissance musculaire de l'humanité par
un facteur de plusieurs centaines dit
autrement si les machines n'existait pas
avec une humanité de 8 milliards
d'individus n'utilisant que ses bras et
ses jambes
le pib mondial serait divisé par deux
sens je peux vous dire que bercy sera
les cheveux blancs l'ain donc en fait
les recettes fiscales de bercy repose en
totalité sur l'énergie en totalité
l'énergie c'est la puissance économique
parce que les machines c'est la
puissance économique les machines c'est
à dire l'énergie ont totalement déformé
la structure des métiers et du reste
permis l'organisation
vous avez ici la structure des métiers
en france il ya deux siècles alors il ya
deux siècles un pardon de ya deux
siècles a aujourd'hui ce que vous
constatez c'est qu'il ya deux siècles
les deux tiers des agriculteurs des deux
tiers des français je vais y arriver
décidément sont agriculteurs paysans
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que les paysans sont tellement peu
productifs que ils arrivent à se nourrir
eux plus une demi personne qui fait
autre chose
c'est ça le fait que les deux tiers de
la france soit dans l'agriculture
1 c'est que un paysan peut se nourrir
lui plus d'une demi personne qui fait
autre chose une traduction économique de
la même chose
c'est qu'au premier ordre le budget
alimentaire des ménages
le budget alimentaire des ménages c'est
les deux tiers de ce qu'ils gagnent
d'accord donc en 1800 les deux tiers des
revenus des ménages
c'est de la nourriture est ce que vous
savez quelle est la part aujourd'hui à
peu près 10%
donc quand on dit que la nourriture vaut
cher c'est pas vrai hélas jamais été
aussi peu cher qu'aujourd'hui parce que
en plus dans le même temps la quantité
de viande par personne a augmenté d'un
facteur 5
ça c'est très peu cher de se nourrir
aujourd'hui et ça va pas durer du reste
quand l'énergie deviendra contrainte
la part de l'alimentation dans le budget
des ménages mais augmentera donc deux
tiers de d'agriculteurs a envoyé que
cette part
enfin le nombre d'agriculteurs
exactement augmente jusqu'en 1850 et
après ça se met à baisser à cette époque
là comme un agriculteur est capable de
cultiver une superficie données de chant
et bien le nombre d'agriculteurs reflète
la surface à cultiver cette surface à
cultiver augmente jusqu'en 1850 parce
qu'on est toujours un déforestation et à
partir des 10150 elle n'augmente plus et
à ce moment par contre entre en jeu une
industrie naissante qui va faire en
quantité croissante pour les
agriculteurs des socs de charrue des
roues cerclées d'écoliers de trait les
premières moissonneuses batteuses et c
est à ce moment là la productivité
agricole c'est à dire que les paysans
sont progressivement remplacés par des
machines et dont vous pouvez en mettre
de moins en moins pour une surface
donnée après la guerre alors la cera
l'oubli on va mettre à disposition des
agriculteurs détracteurs c'est à dire
des machines les usines d'engrais
c'est à dire des machines et les
phytosanitaires enfin les usines de
phytosanitaires c'est à dire encore des
machines et à ce moment le rendement
céréalier à l'hectare en france est
multiplié par un facteur 5 ans 30 ans
est évidemment
exit les agriculteurs alors les
agriculteurs exit qu'est-ce qu'ils font
une fois qu'ils ont existé
eh bien ils vont grossir les villes dans
lesquelles ils peuvent devenir ouvrier
ou s'occuper de services donc la
naissance des villes est le corollaire
de l'augmentation de l'approvisionnement
énergétique dans le pays
sans approvisionnements énergétiques
croissants ou abondant n'y a pas de
ville parce que le premier besoin c'est
de se nourrir et à ce moment-là
productivité agricole baisse et les gens
retournent manger enfin retourne
cultiver de commenge et l'augmentation
des croquettes pour machine permet de
mettre d'autres machines en
fonctionnement que celles qui sont dans
les champs et notamment des machines
dans les mines puis dans la
transformation de tout ce qui va sortir
de la croûte terrestre métaux matériaux
de carrière etc
alors pendant longtemps
l'approvisionnement énergétique
c'est-à-dire les croquettes pour machine
est allé plus vite que la population a
crû plus vite que la population ça veut
dire que on pouvait avoir un nombre de
machines croissant plus vite que la
population et donc la part de la
population employée dans l'industrie
parce qu'en fait industrie ses
serviteurs de machines pouvaient
augmenter
et puis au moment du choc pétrolier
celle inverse qui se passe la population
se met à croître plus vite que le nombre
de machines et à ce moment exactement
pas pour l'approvisionnement énergétique
se met à croître moins vite que le
nombre de machines et à ce moment vous
avez la part de l'industrie dans
l'emploi qui se met à baisser on a eu
plus de production fait avec beaucoup
moins de machines et comme un emploi
ouvriers c'est parce que les machines
étaient plus grosse c'est une machine
on a eu une baisse de l'emploi ouvrier
pas de la production et enfin ceux que
vous voyez là
l'envolée des services en fait c'est
l'envolée des machines parce que pour
avoir beaucoup de services il faut avoir
beaucoup de choses à administrer les
services ça n'est que l'administration
d'une société complexe
je vais prendre un exemple qui la
voiture si demain matin je ne fabrique
une voiture ce qui est un flux
industriels d'accord avec moi je n'ai
plus besoin de banquier pour financer
les voitures neuves
exit les banquiers qui finance les
voitures neuves dans les services je
n'ai plus besoin d'assureur pour assurer
les voitures neuves
exit les assureurs qui sont dans les
services je n'ai plus besoin de moniteur
d'auto école pour apprendre à conduire
aux gens qui vont acheter une voiture
neuve puisque de toute façon il
il ya plus de voitures neuves à acheter
d'accord exit j'ai plus besoin d'agent
de la circulation pour la partie des
voitures neuves
exit les réacteurs donc vous voyez que
sur la base d'un flux industriels en
fait il ya plein d'emplois de services
qui en découle la construction c'est
exactement pareil
le crédit immobilier c'est le premier
crédit aux particuliers dans tous les
pays occidentaux
si j'arrête d'avoir disponibles des
biens matériels qui sont des immeubles
et bien j'ai tout un pan de service
derrière qui disparaît donc l'idée que
les services pourraient subsister dans
un monde dans lequel il ya plus de flux
physiques c'est une illusion
c'est même l'un verse en fait un monde
très complexe sur le plan des flux
physiques demande beaucoup de services
et beaucoup de services c'est la marque
d'un monde dans lequel il ya énormément
de flux physiques
les etats-unis qui sont le premier
consommateur de pétrole au monde enfin
non maintenant c'est pas pareil avec la
chine et le frac sont encore devant mais
et qui est un très gros producteurs
industriels et qui surtout a une grosse
consommation énergétique par personne
est aussi un pays dans lequel 80% de
l'emploi se trouve dans les services une
grande partie de l'emploi dans les
services ça ne veut pas du tout dire que
l'économie est dématérialisé tout le
contraire ça veut dire que la société
est tellement complexe avait tellement
de flux physiques créé par les machines
qu'il faut plein de gens pour
administrer système quand vous avez une
décrue énergétique qui est tellement
forte qu'elle impacte la production
industrielle ce qui nécessite pas passée
à ce moment là ça a impacté le nombre de
machines pour faire cette production
industrielle mais ça va pas impacter la
production qui a continué à croître si
ces impacts la production industrielle à
ce moment ce qui va augmenter c'est pas
le tertiaire c'est le chômage
donc quand on commence à rentrer sous
stress énergétique
à ce moment vous avez de chômage qui se
développe ce qui s'est passé à partir
des chocs pétroliers et je vais finir en
vous donnant une petite représentation
économique de cette affaire peut-être
que dans cette école on va vous
apprendre de l'économie peut-être que
vous allez lire dans votre vie des
chiffres concernant l'économie qui en ce
moment est un sujet qui importe fin qui
importe pour l'essentiel de la classe
politique et pour beaucoup de gens
l'économie qu'on a théorisé il ya deux
siècles l'a été sur une base qui était
une approximation au premier ordre du
moment qui était que le seul facteur
limitant de la production étaient ceux
qui venaient des hommes eux-mêmes donc
l'économie théorise comme vous le savez
la gestion des ressources rares il ya
deux siècles le seul truc qui est rare
c'est le nombre de gens qui peuvent
bosser et le capital humain déjà
accumulé ya deux siècles on sait pas où
l antarctique en france et pas même pas
qu'il existe on n'a toujours pas été
voir au fond des océans on a à peine
fini de trucider les indiens enfin ma
peine commencée de les trucider les
indiens américains le monde est encore
extrêmement vaste donc le au premier or
le monde est infini et donc on peut ne
pas se préoccuper de la limitation de
l'accès aux ressources naturelles
pas de problème et donc on dit à partir
du moment où quelque chose est infini
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que toute
variation relative fini de quelque chose
d'un phyllis nuls donc on dit on va pas
s'emmerder à mettre des zéro partout
dans les équations si les ressources
naturelles sont infinies alors à ce
moment leur coût est nul dans les
fonctions de production
donc on a théorisé un système qui est
celui vous avez appris à l'école où vous
avez deux facteurs de production dans
l'économie qui sont les bons hommes et
le capital humain et si jamais on a les
deux le supermarché rempli
d'accord on a d'autres productions il
supermarché rempli alors l'ingénieur
arrive derrière et dit ouais enfin si
vous voulez mais enfin pour avoir tous
les atomes qui sont dans les produits
que vous avez au supermarché faut bien
les prendre quelque part sur terre ces
atomes et là où vous les prenez ça
s'appelle des ressources naturelles donc
les ressources naturelles c'est les
mêmes atom que ce que vous allez trouver
dans vos vêtements et vos lunettes sauf
qu'ils sont pas arrangées de la même
manière et on va changer l'arrangement
de ces atomes avec ce qu'on appelle du
travail terre de la transformation et ce
travail il est fait un peu par nous et
beaucoup par les machines
donc voilà une représentation physique
de notre système productif
je prends des ressources naturelles dans
l'environnement et je les transforme
pour en faire autre chose quand vous
faites un bâtiment vous prenez des
ressources dans l'environnement et vous
les transformez prenez du minerai de fer
pour faire du fer les armatures vous
prenez du calcaire pour faire le ciment
vous prenez des granulats dans la nature
pour faire le béton vous prenez de
l'espace au sol qui est une ressource
naturelle pour faire l'emprise foncière
de votre bâtiment
vous prenez de cuivre pour faire les
tuyaux de gaz que vous enfin maintenant
avec du plastique
que vous allez mettre dans le bâti etc
c'est des ressources naturelles
transformé par notre activité
toutes nos productions sont des
ressources naturelles transformé par
notre activité y en a pas une qui fasse
exception à cette règle et le capital
dans cette histoire c'est une boucle
internes au système
alors cette représentation physique
al'avantage de très bien coller à ce que
nous avons observé
regardez par exemple la production
économique mondiale depuis la naissance
de monsieur jesus christ alors c'est pas
le zéro c'est l'an 1 mais excellent et
stupide donc ils démarrent le calendrier
romain à 0 est ce que vous pouvez voir
c'est que tant qu'à pas de machine
il n'y a pas de croissance il n'ya pas
non plus de démocratie on y reviendra
peut-être au moment des questions avec
très peu de machines on a très peu de
croissance et arrivent les croquettes
pour machines à haute dose et à ce
moment on a beaucoup de croissance
si je fais un zoom sur les 60 dernières
années
voilà à quoi ça ressemble vous avez ici
la production économique mondiale mesuré
en euros ici la quantité d'énergie qu'on
utilise c'est à dire la quantité de
machines qu'on a mises au service en
service pardon est ce que vous voyez
c'est que la production économique
mondiale au premier ordre c'est une
fonction linéaire de la quantité
d'énergie qu'on consomme
c'est très simple la macroéconomie
dis moi combien de croquettes pour
machine tu utilises je te dirai combien
de machines tu utilises et du coup je te
dirais qu'elle est au pib alors ça
marche très bien aux bons au niveau
mondial ça marche moins bien un pays par
pays parce que vous avez dcb de bord du
au commerce international
ce qu'avec le commerce international
vous pouvez avoir la valeur ajoutée
c'est-à-dire le pib dans un pays mais
les flux physiques c'est-à-dire
l'énergie dans un autre pays donc on
peut effectivement avoir l'illusion que
le danemark ou la suisse se
dématérialise parce que leur pib
augmente avec leur consommation
domestique qui baissent mais s'ils ont
fermé leurs frontières ça marcherait pas
ça ne marche que parce que les
frontières sont ouvertes et comme
l'essentiel de cette énergie et fossiles
vous avez ici le drame des négociations
climat pour revenir à ce que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure
baisser les émissions de 5 % par an au
premier ordre
c'est baisser le pib de 4% par an il ya
un peu d'efficacité dans l'intervalle
mais c'était
donc tous les gens qui réclament 2 % 2°
pardon de limitation de la hausse des
températures
en fait tu réclames implicitement et ne
se rendent pas compte mais implicitement
ce qu'ils réclament c'est une
contraction de 4% du pib mondial qu'il
faut peut-être faire je suis pas en
train de dire qu'il faut pas le faire
mais ce que je suis en train de dire
c'est que la lutte dans les bon ordre de
grandeur contre le réchauffement
climatique suppose que l'économie
s'arrête d'être en croissance et se met
à être en contraction
je ne pense pas que ce soit ça qu'ils
soient dans la tête de madame hidalgo ni
de quelconques d'un quelconque autre
responsable politique c'est bien pour ça
qu'ils nous ont inventé cette très belle
expression de greenwashing qui s'appelle
la croissance verte comme c'est
indicible ce que je suis en train de
vous expliquer là pour un responsable
politique
alors il invente un conte de fées qui
s'appelle la croissance verte donc la
croissance verte c'est je viole la loi
de conservation de l'énergie
moi ça me pose aucun problème puisque je
suis dans la politique ce système là en
effet si vous avez une contrainte soit
qu'on se la posent
soit qu'elle soit subie parce que toute
façon on aura l'un ou l'autre sur la
quantité de croquettes pour machines
donc le parc de machines en
fonctionnement
vous aurez une contrainte sur la
quantité de produits et de services qui
lie à distribuer c'est à dire le pouvoir
d'achat et si vous avez une contrainte
sur les ressources
vous auriez une contrainte également sur
la même chose je finis avec la voiture
balai l'énergie fossile que nous
utilisons actuellement vient de stocks
qui ont mis des dizaines ou des
centaines de millions d'années à se
constituer donc aux échelles de temps
qui nous intéresse quelques siècles qui
aura de la chance on peut dire que ces
stocks nous sont donnés une fois pour
toute et qu' il ne se renouvelle pas en
cours de partie d'accord donc extraire
du pétrole du sol comme extraire du gaz
comme extraire du charbon comme extraire
du minerai de cuivre comme extraire du
khroub du vanadium ou du tantale et bien
c'est taper dans un stock de départ qui
est donnée une fois pour toutes
d'accord il ya un petit théorique de
maths je sais encore démontré
qui vous dit que quand vous tapez dans
un stock de départ qui est donnée une
fois pour toutes à ce moment la
production annuelle en provenance de ce
stock c'était à l'extraction annuel en
provenance
the stock ne peut rien faire d'autre que
d'être nul à moins l'infini nul à plus
d'un fils y est passé par avec un
maximum absolu entre les deux ça c'est
un théorème de matin s'il ya des gens
qui ont un problème avec le théorème je
peux venir vous le démontrer enfin
taurine de maths en fait ça vient c'est
une application du fait que si vous avez
une fonction dont l'intégrale existe
entre mansle affiliées plus un feeling
en l'occurrence l'intègre ma fonction
c'est l'extraction son intégrale c'est
l'extraction cumuler cette extraction
cumulé nécessairement inférieur aux
stocks extractible de départ partir du
moment où vous avez une fonction
positive et intégrables vous pouvez
montrer que sa valeur moyenne sur
n'importe quel intervalle nul par
exemple la production annuelle est bien
nuls à moins l'infini nul à + l'infini
et passe par accident absolue entre les
deux taurines de maths donc le la
production annuelle de pétrole passera
par un maximum absolu dans les temps
historiques pour décliner inexorablement
derrière c'est pas un complot d'écolo ou
le délire de greta tout une berge pas
non non c'est un terrain de maths donc
c'est un truc sérieux
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
moi je m'intéresse à ce sujet depuis 20
ans et depuis vingt ans les pétroliers
que je connaisse qui sont techniquement
compétents et qui veut parle entre la
poire et le fromage me dise le pic de
production mondiale c'est 2020 plus ou
moins cinq ans fait 20 ans qu'il dit ça
en ce qui concerne alors il se battait
avec d'autres copains à eux qui disaient
non dans le pix et 2006 alors en fait
ils ont tous les deux raison en 2006
2008 dit l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie peu importe a eu lieu le pic
du pétrole dits conventionnels
c'est à dire celui qui se trouve dans
des gisements ordinaire en 2018
probablement a eu lieu le pic du pétrole
en rajoutant le ch lors il s'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle le pétrole
de schiste en français qu'on devrait
appeler du pétrole de roche-mère en fait
qui c'est qui est principalement
exportés aux états unis et qui est du
pétrole de fonds de tiroir c'est un truc
de moins bonne qualité mais dont on
connaît l'existence depuis un certain
temps et de toute façon
viendra un moment probablement assez
proche et peut-être que le covin nous
l'a déjà fait passer dans lequel
après lequel pardon la quantité totale
de pétrole dont on dispose année après
année baissera quoi qu'on pense
l'étudiant voulant partir en avion en
erasmus et quoi qu'en pensent les
automobilistes français et quoi qu'en
pense la personne qui veut se chauffer
au fioul a de toute façon
d'ailleurs en baissant pas ce que c'est
les maths je vais vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui la classe politique
ignore totalement ce problème comme
l'ignorent du reste changements
climatiques m'en faut au moins le
changement climatique elle croit qu'elle
connaît ce qui n'est pas vrai en ce qui
concerne le pétrole elle ne croit même
pas qu'elle connaît juste elle a rien
compris au film quoi donc le cette
affaire là alors pourquoi est-ce que je
vous parle du pétrole en particulier
parce que le pétrole au sein de toutes
les énergies qui structure le système
productif mondiale est la plus
limitantes de tout et vous avez ici un
graphique qui vous donne deux variations
depuis quelques décennies en rouge vous
avez la variation de la quantité pas du
prix de la quantité de pétrole qui sort
du sol et en bleu vous avez la variation
du pib par personne dans le monde
ce que vous voyez c'est que depuis les
chocs pétroliers où on a gratté tout ce
qu'on pouvait gratter en termes
d'économie facile et bien le pib répond
chaque année très exactement à la
variation de la quantité de pétrole qui
sort du sol et quand il ya un décalage
temporel c'est le pétrole qui précèdent
le pib ce qui est normal puisque encore
une fois pour faire du pib c'est à dire
de la transformation faut mettre des
machines en action donc avoir de
l'énergie
donc si vous avez moins d'énergie en
particulier moins d'énergie pour
transporter parce que le pétrole et
l'énergie de la transmet du transport
par excellence 98% des moyens de
transport sur terre utilisent du pétrole
et bien si vous en avez - vous
transportez - si vous transportez - la
machine globale mondialisée produits -
c'est aussi bête que ça
voilà ça je vais passer parce que j'ai
pas le temps et je vais finir avec ça on
parlera de ça donc ce que je vous ai
exposé pendant cette grosse heure et
demie c'est que pour les années qu'il
reste à vivre à l'humanité on va se
retrouver de façon croissante à devoir
gérer un dilemme qui est que ou bien on
laisse dériver de façon importante avec
un effet retard des perturbations
environnementales
qui causeront des effets délétères ou
bien on se serre la ceinture pour éviter
ce qu'on peut éviter dans ces
perturbations au risque à ce moment de
faire imploser les structures sociales
parce que la contrainte sera trop forte
et à partir de maintenant
alors en fait ça fait 10 ans ou 20 ans
qu'on est déjà dans cet état là est
d'accord j'ose pas contraindre les
automobilistes un peu trop mais je les
contrats quand même et dont je me tape à
la fois les gilets jaunes et les
incendies en californie
pour le moment j'ai déjà les deux et
bien malheureusement plus le temps
passera et plus on aura ce genre de
dilemme qui va s'intensifier et plus on
se devra osciller entre de la contrainte
de court terme et l'accumulation de
quelque chose d'encore plus violent mais
un peu plus tard
ça va être ça vraiment le monde dans
lequel on va devoir vivre alors c'est
peut-être pas très joyeux à savoir mais
malheureusement c'est le contexte dans
lequel on va livre et je vais finir par
à dernier un dernier
conclusion j'ai envie de dire lié à ça
il vous appartiendra temps que nous
vivons en démocratie c'est à dire dans
un monde de promesses de conte de fées
il vous appartiendra dans les métiers
que vous ferez de temps en temps de
devoir tenir tête aux fantaisies avancé
pour motif d'élection par les gens pour
lesquels vous travaillerez ça sera pas
simple un certain nombre d'entre vous
n'y arriveront pas du reste dans les
gens de mon âge qui sont devenus aux
fonctionnaires une bonne partie quand
ils ont réussi en foutu le camp parce
qu'il n'arrivait pas à gérer cette
schizophrénie mais j'insiste là dessus
vous aurez très probablement dans votre
vie professionnelle à gérer des
situations un peu schizophrénique et un
peu conflictuelle liés à ce que je vous
ai raconté
parce que vous serez pris en tenaille
entre des gens qu'on pas envie d'en
tenir compte parce qu'ils pensent que
leur élection à court terme est plus
importante
est ce que vous saurez pensez-y un peu à
l'avant ce parce que mieux vous êtes
préparés à ce genre de situation eh bien
vous vous en sortirez et j'ai terminé
il ya un courage de la ba 106 souligné
li na tion voir une aisance des
politiques de la gestion de cette crise
de cette situation qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire entendre soit pas accéder la
connaissance obtient au niveau des
élites et des politiques minima choses
un peu le dans la dans le système
démocratique dans lequel on vit on a
souvent tendance à faire une erreur de
lecture sur la façon dont fonctionne le
monde politique alors je vais faire un
tout petit sondage qui dans cette salle
à des parents qui travaillent dans une
entreprise ou une administration qui
dans cette salle à des parents qui sont
élus à un niveau important voilà alors
le résultat de ce sondage minutes dont
vous pouvez voir comme moi la différence
importante des bras qui s'lève d'un côté
et de l'autre montrent que l'expérience
de la relation hiérarchique au travail
que vous avez tous dans votre cercle
familial sauf exception c'est une
relation dans laquelle vous travaillez
dans une structure dans laquelle il ya
un vrai chef qui est capable de vraiment
vous faire de vous emmerder si jamais
vous faites pas ce qui vous demande
alors moi je suis chef d'entreprise les
salariés chez moi je les embauches pour
faire de l'analyse du conseil ou tenir
la comptabilité et si demain matin ils
décident qu'ils ont envie de faire
pousser des carottes sur le toit de
l'immeuble
je leur dis non la porte c'est par là
d'accord lens
j'entends bien auxerre dans ma boîte
mais c'est pour ils d'accord donc j'ai
ce pouvoir donc c'est on a l'habitude de
penser que j'ai envie de dire l'action
dans le monde qui nous entoure avec un
chef et sytchev est convaincu que c'est
par là qu'il faut aller
il est en mesure d'imposer à ses troupes
d'aller dans la direction d'accor donc
si moi je dis maintenant on va
s'attaquer au marché anglais et bien les
troupes seront tenus de s'attaquer au
marché anglais dans une administration
c'est pareil eh bien il se trouve que
dans le monde politique le chef n'est
pas un chef c'est un exécuteur testament
r donc la pyramide est inversé le chef
en fait c'est un élu qui subit et qui
obéit aux pressions des gens qui l'ont
porté là où il est donc là il va pas
dire je vais vous dire ce qu'il faut
faire il va le dire autant que ses
électeurs lui dise voilà ce qu'on veut
et s'il dit tient demain matin pour le
bien de l'humanité
je vais prendre tous les habitants de
paris et gelé délocalise dans le pas de
calais et bien donc ça marche pas alors
que moi dans mon entreprise j'ai la
possibilité de déménager le siège social
1 d'établissement ce que je veux
ailleurs je peux le faire
donc ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
dans le monde politique
en fait il ne suffit pas que le chef il
est la connaissance technique pour
qu'ils prennent les bonnes décisions qui
soient capables d'imposer aux autres
par contre ce qui est sûr c'est que
quand on vient lui demander des trucs
qui n'a pas la connaissance technique il
y là un élément de moins d'appréciation
pour être capable de rendre ses
arbitrages
parce que je le redis un élu ça fait des
arbitrages donc la raison pour laquelle
monsieur macron vient de se créer son
sparadrap du capitaine haddock là avec
son histoire d'amis ch
et bien c'est
une des explications possibles c'est que
il est en train de lorgner vers
l'électorat extrémiste en se disant bon
mon électorat centriste il commence à se
lasser un peu de moi donc je vais aller
regarder ailleurs et si c'est
effectivement ça la bonne explication
ça veut dire que vous n'êtes pas dans le
cadre d'un raisonnement pour le bien de
la collectivité
vous êtes dans le cadre d'un destin
personnel où vous dites à qui il faut
que je parle pour avoir des appuis et un
élus en général c'est comme ça qu'ils
raisonnent ce qui veut dire que si on
veut que les élus changent de
comportement
certes il faut les leur dire ça serait
quand même bien vous compreniez de quoi
il retourne mais il faut aussi que dans
la société civile
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui
fassent pression sur eux en audience et
par là qu'on veut aller voilà c'est ça
donc il faut les deux ingrédients
il suffit pas qu'il sache pour prendre
tout d'un coup des décisions très
différentes
alors que dans le monde de l'entreprise
la l'impact de la compréhension du
problème à traiter est plus important
parce que les pouvoirs du chef sont plus
réelle j'ai envie de dire ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas les obliger à se
former mais mais mais ça suffira - j'ai
envie de dire ce que ça peut faire quand
même c'est éviter quelques conneries ce
qui est déjà beaucoup
prendre une question qui a été longtemps
roulé sur question ici on direct par les
élèves je laisse pousser yat-il
consensus au sein du haut conseil pour
le climat quant à la nécessité de
rentrer rempli croissance économique
quels arguments sont autour la réponse
est non il n'y a pas vraiment l'argument
est
[Musique]
alors je veux dire un peu plus
longuement
la réponse est non et la réponse est non
parce que dans la littérature économique
il ne se trouve aujourd'hui pas beaucoup
d'articles qui souligne cette nécessité
or le haut conseil à deux règles de
fonctionnement
la première c'est que on a décidé de ne
rien publier qui ne soit pas le reflet
d'une unanimité ce qui me va très bien
je n'ai pas de problème avec ça et de
comme au sein du haut conseil
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui
viennent du monde
habitués à la publication dans des
revues à comité de lecture
dans ce monde là on considère que les
informations dont on a le droit de faire
état dans une communication publique
doivent préalablement avoir passé ce
filtre alors j'y suis extrêmement
favorable pour les sciences dures parce
que c'est quelque chose qui dans les
sciences dures vous avez des lois qui en
sont vraiment qu'ils sont universels
dans leur domaine de validité et qui
doivent conduire à des expérimentations
au résultat prévisible dans ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler les sciences sociales
qui en fait sont pas vraiment des
sciences puisqu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment de loi totalement prévisibles
je pense que ça se discute un peu plus
et en particulier en matière d'économie
comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure
l'économie a été théorisée aujourd'hui
avec une approximation au premier ordre
qui ne correspond pas du tout à la
situation physique que nous connaissons
dans la théorie économique classique
rien ne vous dis que dans le monde
physique
la théorie vous dit que vous ne pouvez
pas faire 40000 km à la surface de la
terre le long d'un cercle
sans revenir à votre point de départ
dont vous avez une limite absolue à la
distance que vous êtes capable de
parcourir sur un grand cercle
sans revenir à votre point de départ
dans la théorie économique
il n'y a rien qui vous dise à partir du
moment où le pib mondial aura atteint
100 mille 352 milliards de dollars ça
s'arrête
d'accord donc l'idée qu' il pourrait y
avoir une limite absolue au pib pour des
raisons environnementales est quelque
chose qui n'a jamais été formulée dans
la théorie économique
enfin dans les résultats techniques pour
l'excellente raison que la modélisation
même du système ne permet pas de
discuter de ceux de ce point là donc
vous avez au sein du haut conseil des
gens qui disent y'a rien de prouvé sur
l'impossibilité de découpler ce qui est
formellement vrai donc on voit pas
pourquoi il faudrait rentrer en
décroissance pour limiter le co2 voilà
moi ma conviction elle est liée au fait
que le fait de basculer des énergies
carbonées vers les énergies décarbonées
pas se faire à la bonne vitesse il
suffit d'une règle de trois qu'on montre
et ça s'appelle l'équation de callas
pour ceux d'entre vous que ça intéresse
il ya une page sur mon site qui
s'appelle qu'est-ce que l'équation de
kaya sur mon site perso jancovici points
comme vous irez voir c'est une règle de
trois et il suffit de décomposer cette
règle de trois pas à pas pour se rendre
compte que d'aller à la bonne vitesse
sur les émissions de co2 sans rentrer
dans une contraction du pib mondial
je considère que les données
d'observation qu'on a pas théorique mais
l'observation interdit d'envisager cette
possibilité mais il n'y a pas du tout de
consensus au sein du haut conseil pour
formuler ce genre de par contre des
débats ce qui est déjà une excellente
chose parce que au moins on en discute
entre nous
j'avais parlé juste avant que mon
politique et avec 40 cas votre
entreprise vous conseillez vous aux
exemples aux prises de tête font partie
du cac 40
c'est toi les réactions des entreprises
qui gèrent du midi vous êtes déjà allés
au cinéma
si je vous demande c'est quoi la
réaction de l'ensemble des étudiants de
la iv p face aux derniers films de je ne
sais pas qui
aux derniers pirates des caraïbes bien
et bien je ne suis pas complètement sûr
que vous allez avoir quelque chose de
totalement unanime d'accord puis les
gens combien d mais c'est pas sûr qu'ils
ont bien aimé la même chose
bon alors le sens de cette petite
parabole c'est qu'une entreprise c'est
pas plus monolithique pas moins que les
gens qu'il ya dans cette salle c'est
lorsqu'il vous rassemble c'est de faire
les mêmes études pour autant que vous
avez quand même un certain nombre de
différences entre goûts et les
différences de point de vue des
différences de goût de couleurs etc
deux pays d'origines de cultures bref
une entreprise c'est pareil donc en fait
c'est pas beau politique une entreprise
et donc ça n'a pas une réaction
monolithique donc une entreprise ne
réagit pas ce qui est important c'est de
savoir à quoi ressemblent les réactions
des gens qui sont dans l'entreprise et
là c'est une petite société en miniature
quand vous avez affaire à un groupe du
cac c'est n'importe quoi entre les
foncières c'est à part mais on va dire
ça se balade entre 50000 et 500000
personnes qui y bossent
donc c'est une ville la taille d'une
ville et vous avez de tous entre le
patron et l'employé de base entre les
gens qui sont dans un pays et les gens
qui sont dans un autre entre les hommes
et les femmes entre les jeunes et les
vieux etc
vous avez alors une fois que je vous ai
dit ça
ce que je constate sur les dix dernières
années c'est qu'il est devenu beaucoup
plus facile de s'inviter pour discuter
de ce genre de choses dans les
entreprises d'une manière générale que
ça n'était le cas il ya 10 ou 15 ans
la deuxième chose que je constate c'est
qu'il commence à y avoir un clivage
générationnel c'est à dire que les
jeunes sont plus allants et pousse plus
à la roue pour qu'on s'occupe du
problème que les moins jeunes
mais ça c'est normal une fois qu'on a
mon âge on est en croûte et dans ses
habitudes donc il y en a pas des gens
pour vous botter les fesses on bouge pas
la troisième chose que je constate c'est
que il ya le climat c'est très très
difficile d'en faire autre chose que un
codicille positif d'une action que vous
auriez entreprises pour une autre raison
donc en fait ce qu'il faut trouver dans
les entreprises c'est des actions qu'ils
possèdent des bénéfices de court terme
qui par ailleurs sont aussi bonne pour
le climat
c'est comme ça qu'on fait bouger les
boîtes donc se faire hara kiri quand
vous appelez rdo tout simplement parce
que comme ça il y aura moins de voitures
à pétrole en circulation sur terre c'est
une pas une option envisageable du point
de vue de dos je vous pouvez regretter
mais c'est pas une option envisageable
donc quand vous êtes à l'intérieur de
renault par contre c'est une option
envisageable de vendre des voitures
électriques plutôt que des voitures à
pétrole
en france où ça fait effectivement
baisser les émissions si vous avez
des gens qui vous demandent des voitures
électriques plutôt que des voitures à
pétrole à ce moment vous êtes très
contents de les re de leurs mandants
parce que ça vous fait crottés et
accessoirement vous dire que c'est bon
pour climat mais ce n'est pas la
première raison pour laquelle vous le
faites vous le fait parce qu'il ya une
demande et que vous en fournit c'est
donc le tout la science j'ai envie de
dire de carbone 4 c'est d'arriver à
trouver dans les entreprises
1 la bonne métriques pour comprendre où
on en est et savoir se repérer par
rapport aux problèmes et 2
c'est tout ce qui va autour de la
comptabilité carbone et de identifier
toutes les actions qui sont à
l'intersection de l'entreprise y gagne
quelque chose et le climat il ya quelque
chose ça dépend énormément des
entreprises et en fonction des actions
qu'on a en tête au sein des entreprises
ça plaît at-elle interlocuteurs et des
plaies à telle autre par exemple quand
ça conduit à rééquilibrer les activités
ça plaît à la personne qui pilotent
l'activité qui va augmenter et ça
déplaît fortement la personne qui
pilotent l'activité qui doit se
contracter
donc le l'idée que les entreprises c'est
un truc monolithique au sein desquels
vous êtes vous êtes en blanc et noir en
fait c'est pas une vision qui correspond
à la réalité la vision qui correspond à
la réalité c'est le nombre de deux
points d'appui et de prix ce que vous
pouvez avoir à l'intérieur de cet
univers là pour faire avancer le
schmilblick et ça ça augmente pas assez
vite
très clairement pas assez vite mais ça
augmente quand même mais pas assez vite
j'insiste là dessus il faudrait alors
dernier point important les entreprises
innovent que sous la contrainte
tu vois je suis chef d'entreprise une
entreprise ninove que sous la contrainte
la contrainte de ses compétiteurs la
contrainte de ses collaborateurs qui se
barre si les choses sont pas bien fait
que sous la contrainte donc lié qu'il
faudrait pas contraindre les entreprises
parce que c'est vrai
et il faut contraindre les entreprises
si on veut avancer et si on veut avancer
vite faut les contraindre beaucoup donc
ça c'est un des points qui m'oppose
fortement à la représentation patronale
classique qui consiste à dire nous
envers dépannage reviennent assez de
problèmes comme ça et c'est peut-être
mais enfin vous avez compris toute façon
les problèmes ils vont pas disparaître
demain matin donc temps vous êtes encore
debout je vais vous en rajoutez une
couche c'est ça le truc est utile à
faire une question
vous allez manger leur amour
l'internaute
j'en ajouterai que les os x était pas
viable
ah si si c'est viable mais pas au
pouvoir d'achat que vous avez
aujourd'hui il ya deux manières de
prendre la question sur le dispositif
énergétique
il ya une manière qui est de se fixer
des objectifs d'abord et de voir comment
on y arrive ensuite il ya une manière
qui consiste à regarder ce qu'on peut
toujours faire à court terme et de
regarder où ça nous emmène ensuite le
souvent en dans l'action publique j'ai
envie de dire c'est la deuxième manière
de faire qui est la manière la plus
couramment répandue
d'accord les gens peu sera vous raconter
ce qu'ils veulent sur les arbitrages à
2050 à 2100 et c'est en fait ce qui
compte c'est entre quoi et quoi ils ont
le choix demain matin alors si on veut
avancer j'ai envie de dire sur le
problème convient d'évoquer vous avez
compris qu'en fait c'est l'abondance
énergétique qui a structuré la totalité
du monde dans lequel on vit
y compris le fait qu'aujourd'hui on est
capable d'avoir des respirateurs
artificiels pour les gens qu'on rattrape
et le colisée qui sont pas bien tout ça
vient de l'énergie dans un monde qui
aura moins d'énergie vous allez avoir
globalement une contraction structurelle
de nos moyens
donc la question c'est comment vouliez
rares chizé vos renoncement et qu'est ce
que vous faites en premier ma vision des
choses c'est que dans cet univers là
vous commencez par mettre en premier
vous par mettre en oeuvre en premier les
actions qui vont éviter le plus de
problèmes
par unités d'oeuvre que vous avez à
votre disposition
donc par exemple les actions si vous
décidez que l'on résume le travail
humain au travers d euros les actions
qui ont le coût à la tonne de co2 le
plus bas de quoi la tonne de co2 évitée
par dont le plus bas c'est les actions
que vous mettez en oeuvre d'abord parce
que c'est là qu'avec la même quantité de
personnes vous allez éviter le plus de
co2
au travers de ce que vous faites alors
de ce point de vue déployer du nucléaire
c'est beaucoup plus rapide pour éviter
du co2 que de déployer de l'éolien ou du
solaire beaucoup plus rapide donc si
vous pensez que le chaos climatique est
à nos portes
vous ne commencez pas par faire des
panneaux solaires et des éoliennes au
surplus en france pour remplacer du
nucléaire ce qui ne va rien changer au
chaos climatique donc ça changera rien
au nombre de réfugiés qui vont venir
d'afrique
ça changera rien au dépérissement
agricole en france et ça changera rien
aux incendies de forêt et à la mort des
coraux change rien à sa par contre si
vous voulez changer quelque chose il
faut virer les 2200 gigawatts de
centrales à charbon qui est sur terre et
là ça ira plus vite si on remplace une
partie de sa part du nucléaire que si on
remplace une partie de sa part de
l'éolien du solaire regard plus vite
donc pour moi le nucléaire il n'est pas
en compétition avec le charbon pour eux
c'est tout vu ça il faut il est en
compétition avec le solaire et l'éolien
dans la mesure où ils ont fait l'un ou
l'autre mais en trente ans on va pas
faire l'un puis l'autre et puis etc
on n'a pas de siècle on a 30 ans donc ce
qu'il faut faire sur l'énergie ces deux
choses il faut d'une part organiser la
sobriété mais qui est une contraction du
pouvoir d'achat alors un exemple typique
de sobriété c'est les gens se balader en
bagnole et vous leur demander de se
balader dès qu'ils sont seuls en vélo
électrique par exemple ça c'est de la
sobriété
le vélo électrique s'apaisent quand même
à peu près 20 kg la voiture électrique
une tonne et demie donc vous voyez le
vélo électrique qui pèse 70 fois moins
que la voiture électrique dont qui
consomment 70 fois moins de métal de
ressources de ceci de cela pour faire la
batterie et ses batteries et 100 fois
plus petites donc ça c'est une grosse
sobriété passer de la voiture à essence
à la voiture électrique c'est pas
vraiment la sobriété c'est un changement
de technologie mais c'est pas vraiment
vous continuez à avoir un truc d'une
tonne et demie et même du reste deux et
demi parce qu'on fait des temples
électrique en ce moment
dans lequel vous vous baladez dans vos
fauteuils en cuir donc j'ai pas vraiment
de la sobriété c'est un changement
technique
donc il faut à la fois faire de la
sobriété et sur la partie
approvisionnements énergétiques
décarbonés le plus vite possible alors
en france on a déjà décarbonés la
production électrique
là dessus le job est fait si on veut
aller plus loin il faut supprimer le
pétrole et le gaz
supprimer le pétrole et le gaz ça veut
dire supprimer le gaz dans le chauffage
et le pétrole dans le chauffage ça c'est
pas très compliqué vous isoler les
bâtiments et vous passez à la pompe à
chaleur et aux voix voilà dans des
proportions qui préserve les forêts qui
doivent être renouvelés par ailleurs
parce que de façon les arbres existants
vos moyens et du corps du côté de la
mobilité
là vous êtes obligés d'avoir des moyens
plus léger qui vous permettront d'aller
moins loin et pour plus cher
et voilà et enfin du côté de l'industrie
vous avez un mix des deux c'est à dire
que vous pouvez pas tout électrifié avec
des réacteurs nucléaires supplémentaires
donc il va falloir se faire à l'idée
qu'on va diviser par 2 3 4 5
les flux de matières de plastique
d'acier et ses livres heureux avec ça
voilà en gros le panorama général donc
il n'y a pas juste le sujet du nucléaire
c'est un sujet plus large
est-ce que j'ai coutume de dire c'est
que plus on refuse le nucléaire est plus
l'effort sur la sobriété volontaire ou
subie au quelqu'un à ce moment ça
s'appelle de la pauvreté sera violent
c'est ça le csah l'arbitrage
son compère c'est simplement pour
continuer la question à propos d'un
projet justement des sorties la main
gauche à droite
que c'est un lapin blanc sorti du
chapeau donc si j'étais en face du
ministre au moment où il fait cette
annonce je lui demanderais si met sa
main droite et sa main gauche sur le bio
avec la schl au dessus en disant je
signe voilà je pas complètement sûr qui
persisteraient alors une fois que j'ai
fait cette réponse là qui devait faire
une réponse un peu plus circonstanciée
l'hydrogène aujourd'hui comme vous le
savez probablement il en existe plein
plein plein dans la nature le problème
c'est que partout où ils se trouvent
il est difficilement accessible sous
forme libre alors déjà de l'hydrogène
vous en avez des tetra chier dans le
soleil
enfin c'est un peu compliqué d'y aller
pour faire son plein donc celui là il
est pas trop accessible et après vous en
avez énormément sur terre dans une
molécule toute simple qui est disponible
partout qui s'appelle l'eau sauf que
dans l'eau l'eau est un occident comme
on dit oxyde de carbone
donc l'eau il faut de l'énergie pour
réduire parce que sinon l'hydrogène
reste cramponné à son atome d'oxygène
dont il est éperdument amoureux
donc il faut séparer des deux sexes
séparés des amoureuse compliquée donc le
et l'énergie que vous allez utiliser
pour séparer l'oxygène de l'hydrogène
dans la molécule d'eau c'est plus que
l'énergie que l'hydrogène dernière
fournira quand vous allez le brûler ou
leurs combinés à de l'eau dans une pile
à combustible qui aura eu des pertes
entre temps donc la civilisation de
l'hydrogène propre est une civilisation
dans laquelle des tas de gens imaginent
qu'on va construire des forêt
d'éoliennes pour l'électrolysé de l'eau
quand il aura du vent pour ensuite le
stocker pour ensuite s'en servir
dans des applications fixes ou dans les
transports alors j'ai fait un tout petit
calcul
je vais finir par ça moi j'adore les
règles de trois il ya un autre truc que
je dis à mes étudiants en permanence cd
que vous êtes face à un problème fait
une règle de trois pouvaient pas savoir
le nombre de conneries qu'on pourrait
éviter si on faisait ça le politique
n'aime pas faire des règles de trois et
même dans les entreprises
des fois on bon alors il d'autres où je
vous propose est la suivante aujourd'hui
on consomme 40 millions de tonnes de
pétrole par an dans les transports
encore donc entre l'avion à hydrogène
qui va venir tout sourit donc entre les
avions les poids lourds et les voitures
40 millions de tonnes pour produire la
même quantité d'hydrogène exactement la
même quantité d'énergie mécanique dans
les véhicules avec de l'hydrogène parce
que le rendement de la pile à
combustible est un peu meilleure eh bien
il faudrait que on double la production
électrique en france la production
totale pas la production éolienne juste
à partir d'éoliennes
ce qui veut dire qu'on installerait en
france aujourd'hui en ordre de grandeur
cinq à six fois le parc allemand
d'éoliennes
rien que pour produire l'hydrogène qui
seraient utilisés dans les moyens de
transport est encore dans ce calcul j'ai
été sympa avec les pertes en cours de
route est ce que vous pensez
sérieusement qu'on va installer en
france dans un contexte qui sera
récessif
car le contexte est récessif 5 à 6 fois
la production allemande
la production éolienne allemande pour
être capable de faire de l'hydrogène
pour faire voler des avions propres et
des voitures propres
enfin par une voiture ont pas volés et
oui pas une seconde et même le quart de
sart pas une seconde par seconde
sans compter qu'il faut déjà qu'on sur
pleins d'éoliennes pour faire baisser le
nucléaire parce que c'est vachement
important donc ça vient vraiment plus à
quand donc le on est typiquement dans du
temps du temps du pipeau politique pour
finir par un propos un peu générale il
ya dix ou quinze ans il y avait un
discours sur le changement climatique
qui consistait à nier les faits qui
s'appelait le climato-scepticisme
aujourd'hui en france ce discours n'est
quasiment plus audible alors il est
probablement audible auprès d'une partie
de l'électorat mais il n'est plus
audible auprès de ce que je pourrais
qualifier sans que ce soit prétentieux
de dire ça auprès de ce que je ferais
qualifié d élite tard qu'aujourd'hui
tombé sur un dirigeant d'entreprise
d'une grande boîte ou tombés sur un
grand élu qui vous tient un discours
ouvertement climato sceptiques
peut-être qu'après sa dernière sortie
mac on va essayer mais jusqu'à
maintenant
d'accord c'est un combat qui et gagner
celui-là il c'est derrière nous mais le
grand n'importe quoi
il est passé et non pas de la définition
du problème il est passé de la
définition du problème pardon aux
solutions aux problèmes c'est à dire
qu'en fait le grand n'importe quoi est
passé du climatoscepticisme au
greenwashing est donc maintenant vous
avez des discours qui fleurissent
partout encore il ya trois jours il ya
google qui a expliqué qu'il allait
devenir même pas neutre mais transparent
google va devenir transparent qu'est ce
que va faire google google va non
seulement devenir notre ce que tu me
connais face qui n'a pas de
commanditaire de l'existence sur le plan
physique cela n'existe pas la neutralité
d'un seul individu mais en plus ils vont
passer l'épongé derrière toutes leurs
émissions passées encore ils vont
respirer tout le co2 passé et donc ils
vont devenir transparent invisibles ils
n'ont jamais existé
oui
si google n'avait jamais existé ça
serait pareil parce qu'ils sont neutres
sur la totalité de leur durée de vie
c'est du grand n'importe quoi
évidemment google est une entreprise qui
vit de la pression publicitaire puisque
leur métier consiste à faire du ciblage
publicitaire comme vous le savez très
bien donc leur métier consiste à inciter
des tas de gens à consommer des trucs
qui leur sont pas indispensables pas
complètement sûr que ce soit neutre du
point de vue climatique
ensuite google a besoin des terminaux
que les gens achètent pour pouvoir
utiliser leurs services
objectivement les services des
publicitaires donc des tablettes des
smartphones des ordinateurs faut les
fabriquer google a besoin de l'existence
d'un réseau de télécommunications
mondiales sinon google n'existe pas
google a besoin de ses serveurs à
fabriquer et à faire fonctionner google
a besoin de tout ça et dire tout d'un
coup je vais devenir invisible pour le
climat ça revient à dire que rien de
tout ça existe ça revient à dire ça
ce qui est évidemment une vue de
l'esprit donc c'est un discours de qom
discours de comme la neutralité au
niveau d'une entreprise n'a pas de
réalité physique ça voudrait dire que
cette entreprise est capable par sa
seule volonté de s'abstraire elle et
quelques arbres bien choisis du destin
du reste du monde
c'est ça que ça voudrait dire avec ce
que je vous ai raconté vous y croyez bon
donc ça n'a aucun sens la neutralité est
en fait c'est même pire que ça c'est une
faute de management parce que une fois
qu'à l'intérieur d'une entreprise vous
avez dit que vous êtes neutre vous avez
par construction anesthésier la totalité
de vos collaborateurs qui vous avez dit
le problème est réglé
donc vous avez tué leur créativité et
vous avez tué leur aptitude à vous
trouver des bonnes idées pour continuer
à être partiellement maître de votre
destin dans le monde que j'ai évoqués
donc non seulement c'est un non sens
physique mais c'est une faute
managériale alors des du grand n'importe
quoi sur les solutions il en sort tous
les jours c'est vrai plus aucun plus
aucun problème et c'est bien ça le
problème c'est que la presse passe les
plats parce que la presse n'ait pas de
règle de 3 avant de passer les plats
donc elle prend le communiqué de presse
il a fait copier coller cousin et
dernière question
sur le devenir des villes dans ce
contexte est aussi ce que vous
ce que vous demanderiez alors je vais je
les ai pas j'ai pas eu tort de le faire
aujourd'hui mais chez vos collègues de
centrale nantes j'avais passé dans une
intervention encore plus longue
qu'aujourd'hui mais le matin donc c'est
donc il y avait moins faim le
il ya tout un passage qui concerne la
question des villes alors le premier
besoin des gens en ville c'est de manger
du reste je pense que l'un certains
d'entre vous doivent commencer à avoir
l'estomac dans les talons en dix ans
quand est ce que ça se termine bientôt
rassurez vous donc le premier besoin
c'est de manger les gens en ville
manifestement sauf quelques tomates qui
poussent sur les toits d'immeubles mais
enfin c'est pas ça qui va vous faire
bouger toute l'année ne font pas pousser
ce qu'il mange ça veut dire que
historiquement les villes ont eu une
taille qui a été limité numériquement
par le surplus agricoles qui étaient
disponibles dans un disque dont le rayon
était quelques jours de transport alors
quelques jours de transport à l'époque
romaine quand vous êtes à lutèce ces
quelques jours de transport à pinces
éventuellement en char à boeufs et donc
est par ailleurs la productivité
agricole est faible donc le surplus
dégagés par le disque qui fait deux
jours de transport à pied de rayon est
faible et est ce que vous savez quelle
était la taille de la bonne ville de
paris à l'époque à peu près dix mille
foyers à peu près dix mille foyers à
cette époque là la seule ville au monde
qui approche le million d'habitants
sérum et la raison à cela c'est que rome
est capable de vivre en aspirant la
totalité enfin une fraction
significative de la production agricole
égyptienne parce que la production
agricole égyptienne et répartis tout le
long d'une voie de transport
merveilleuse qui s'appelle le nil et
après vous pouvez amener par voie d'eau
les céréales à rome
donc la seule ville qui est capable de
bénéficier non pas d'un disque avec deux
jours de transport à pied mais d'un pays
entier
accessible par le transport maritime
sérum et c'est la seule ville au monde à
cette époque là qui a une taille très
significative même le pari de la
renaissance est encore une ville qui ne
dépassent pas 100 mille habitants donc
dans un monde à l'énergie contrainte
les villes sont de petite taille parce
que le premier besoin des urbains est
temps de manger
vous avez accès à une petite un peu un
petit zone agricole avec un faible
surplus pour être capable de la nourrir
depuis qu'est ce qui s'est passé les
tracteurs et les phytosanitaires ont
fait exploser la quantité de nourriture
disponible et les camions les bateaux et
les avions
répartis partout à la surface de la
planète donc les parisiens mange la
bretagne qui elle-même mange le pantanal
le mato grosso et et c'est parce que le
soja brésilien va alimenter les vaches
et des poulets bretons qui vont
alimenter les parisiens si on revient à
une époque où l'énergie et contingente
où l'énergie est rare tout ce système
s'écroule dans un monde dans lequel je
supprime les camions demain matin les
parisiens meurent de faim d'accord les
parisiens beurre de faim littéralement
puis à bouffer donc dans un monde à
l'énergie
par ailleurs la ville est un lieu
d'échangé donc environ produit rien n'y
a pas de ressources la transformer
les sacs vuitton ce même les habitants
sont pas produits à paris enfin s'ils
sont produits à paris mais les vaches
qui fournissent le cuir n'ont donc dans
une ville tout ce qu'on fait c'est
échanger et du reste quand vous regardez
la façon dont ces structures est une
ville ancienne qui est parfait qui est
beaucoup plus intelligente que la smart
cities j'ai beaucoup l'expression ce
parti comme si les villes actuelles et
et céphalées financier net est stupide
les villes anciennes son remarquable
d'intelligence
c'est quoi une ville ancienne c'est un
lieu des changes
alors comment on a organisé lieu des
changes pour qu'il soit le plus efficace
possible on a mis au centre de la ville
tous les endroits où on échange quelque
chose la place de marché
j'échange les objets l'église ou le
synagogue la mosquée peu importe
j'échange mes croyances et des règles de
morale
la représentation du pouvoir central
labeyrie un prêtre la préfecture au
serveur l'école j'échange des savoirs et
vous pouvez aller vous balader dans
n'importe quel vieux village de france
de navarre et d'europe
vous retrouverez toujours toujours
toujours cette architecture les lieux
des changes au centre et après la ville
organisée de telle sorte que le temps
qui permet aux gens de profiter de ces
lieux des gens je sois minimiser donc il
ya un très bon arbitrage entre
l'étalement horizontal et l'étalement
verticale dont vous allez trouver dans
toutes les vieilles villes de france
n'importe quoi entre du r + 3 dur plus
cinq partout
que vous soyez à strasbourg à paris à
bordeaux ou set partout ça va être ça
parce que ces cycles et la ville en
forme de disque
c'est ce qui permet de minimiser le
temps de déplacement des habitants de la
ville jusqu'aux lieux des changes où il
se passe quelque chose quand on commence
à avoir des bagnoles à ce moment on fait
une banlieue de 100 kilomètres sur 100
kilomètres carrés avec les yeux dans les
coins comment y coluche qui s'appelle
los angeles
mais il a fallu attendre d'avoir une
bagnole pour ça sinon la ville ancienne
elle est compacte est structurée autour
des lieux des changes dans un monde à
l'énergie contrainte
on va avoir moins de trucs à échanger
puisqu'on aura moins de flux physiques
donc la fonction urbaine elle même sera
moins importante
donc les villes vont voir leur rôle
économique baissé aujourd'hui dans la
mondialisation les villes voir leur rôle
économique monte mais c'est une erreur
de lecture de l'histoire de penser qu'il
faut continuer à metropolis et le pays
c'est une erreur
on va la payer cher en déshérence
économique dans pas très longtemps
là le plateau de saclay j'habite pas
très loin donc c'est une excellente
affaire pour le prix de ma maison est
une connerie connerie sans nom
le veto des meilleures terres arables et
d'europe qui alors que l'ile-de-france
n'est pas autosuffisante en bouffe tout
ça pour monter dans le classement de
shanghai juste un truc totalement
délirant le c'est anachronique quoi
j'étais très bien à faire il ya 50 ans
et sur le même terrain que la 5g de
maquereau est un caprice le donc les
villes dans un monde à l'énergie
contraintes vont voir leur leur
pertinence économique et leur vitalité
économique décroître et du reste on
commence à le voir avec des cités
fantômes aux états unis ça ça commence à
arriver ça va augmenter et comme c'est
dans les banlieues est allé que la
fonction des changes de la ville est la
plus dépendante d'énergie abondante
c'est dans ces endroits là que les
problèmes vont se manifester en premier
donc aujourd'hui il faut arrêter la
métropolisation du pays faut faire
l'inversé faut faire dégonfler les
villes une ville durable sera avant tout
une petite ville où il vit dans la
décroissance est géré ce qui veut dire
qu'un des défis qui se posent à nous ça
va être de retourner des bâtiments au
gazon c'est peut-être un tout petit peu
différent de la vision conventionnel que
vous aviez
[Applaudissements]